très bien je quelques annonces avant de
débuter directement dans nos auditions
je viens d'apprendre que notre collègue
du groupe rNL ménage a été agressé à son
domicile samedi dernier et je condamne
ses actes qui ne sont aucunement
acceptables en démocratie et je fais
part à votre groupe ainsi qu'à notre
collègue de notre solidarité la plus
totale
alors si vous m'entendez pas je crois
que là-bas vous m'avez entendu
bien
est-ce que niveau technique vous pouvez
augmenter le volume pour celles et ceux
qui ont du mal à m'entendre
très bien
je continue dans les annonces dans le
cadre de la procédure qui est prévue à
l'article 13 alinéa 5 de la Constitution
la commission auditionnera demain à 9h
Madame Valérie metriche Hecquet que le
Président de la République envisage de
nommer aux fonctions de directrice
générale de l'Office national des forêts
en application de l'article 29-1 de
notre règlement je vous propose de
désigner madame Bénédicte taurine du
groupe LFI comme rapporteur sur cette
proposition de nomination ça va à tout
le monde très bien
autre annonce l'article 145-7 de notre
règlement prévoit que à l'issue d'un
délai de six mois qui suit son entrée en
vigueur les lois dont la mise en oeuvre
nécessite la publication de texte
réglementaire font l'objet d'un rapport
de mise en application et donc à ce site
à ce titre pardon six missions
d'application de loi votée sous la
précédente législature vont être créés
dès cette semaine associent des binômes
de rapporteur qui sont composés en
fonction du Règlement de l'Assemblée et
du tourniquet qui est arrêté par le
bureau je vous propose de nommer dès
aujourd'hui les rapporteurs
d'applications de quatre lois les deux
autres missions seront créées demain
première loi c'est la loi qui vise à
lutter contre la maltraitance animale et
confortait le lien entre les animaux et
les hommes ce sera Anne Laurence Petel
du groupe Renaissance et Daniel Simonet
du groupe LFI on dit ok avec ça très
bien deuxième ça sera la loi pour un
accès plus juste plus un peu plus
transparent au marché de l'assurance
emprunteur ce sera Stéphane Végéta
groupe Renaissance et Philippe naillé
groupe socialiste tout le monde est
d'accord très bien troisième évaluation
ça sera la loi d'orientation relative à
une meilleure diffusion de l'assurance
récolte en agriculture et portant
réforme des outils de gestion des
risques climatiques ce sera Frédéric
descrosaï côté Renaissance rapporteur de
doigts puisqu'il était rapporteur déjà à
l'époque du texte et Julien dive côté LR
tout le monde est OK et le la dernière
évaluation ça sera sur la loi de lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique et de
renforcement de la résilience à ses
effets uniquement sur les articles
relatifs à la com Eco et ça sera Sandra
Marceau côté Renaissance et Florence
Goulet côté RN tout le monde est
d'accord très bien j'en ai fini avec les
annonces et les nominations madame la
ministre mes chers collègues la
commission des affaires économiques elle
reprend ses travaux hors session pour
engager principalement deux cycles
d'audition tout d'abord comme les autres
commissions permanentes et sur la
demande de la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale nous allons entendre tous les
ministres ou presque parce qu'ils sont
nombreux relevant du champ de de notre
commission il s'agira de faire le point
sur leur feuille de route pour les
prochains mois afin d'anticiper les
travaux que nous pourrions mener et on
va essayer d'être ambitieux de
co-construire les textes législatifs et
pour le moins adopter adapter nos
agendas prévoir des missions de contrôle
sur les sujets concernés ou encore
évaluer des textes qui ont été adoptés
dans ces différents domaines ces
dernières années donc dans ce cas nous
recevons aujourd'hui Agnès Penny
rinachée ministre de la transition
énergétique puis Olivier Klein ministre
délégué chargé de la ville et du
logement dans les prochains jours et les
prochaines semaines la commission
éditionnera Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielles et numérique
Roland Lescure ministre délégué et
chargé de l'Industrie Olivia Grégoire
ministre délégué chargé des PME du
Commerce de l'Artisanat et du Tourisme
Marc féno ministre de l'Agriculture et
de la souveraineté alimentaire Jean-Noël
Barrault ministre délégué chargé de la
transition numérique et des
télécommunications Jean-François caraco
ministre délégué chargé des Outre-mer
alors j'ai précisé que cette édition
réalisera en visioconférence pour
permettre aux députés ultramarins d'I
assisté et elle se tiendra à 20h le
mercredi 28 septembre pour rassembler
les députés des Antilles de la Guyane de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon de l'océan
Indien et du Pacifique nous aurons
également la possibilité de recevoir
Olivier belge ministre délégué chargé du
Commerce extérieur de l'attractivité et
des Français de l'étranger et il nous
restera à entendre par la suite à des
dates qui n'ont pas encore été arrêtées
Sylvie retaillaient au Ministre ayant le
portefeuille de la recherche Hervé
Berville secrétaire d'État chargé de la
mer et Marlène Schiappa secrétaire
d'État chargé de le SS
simultanément à l'audition de ces
ministres j'ai souhaité que notre
commission elle puisse s'engager un
autre cycle d'audition sur les questions
énergétiques c'est pourquoi dès le 31
août j'ai fait diffuser un communiqué de
presse annonçant que la Commission
consacrerait sa première réunion à
l'audition d'Agnès ministre de la
transition écologique énergétique puis
elle notre commission entendra
successivement Jean-Bernard Lévy PDG
d'EDF ce sera demain matin sur l'état du
parc nucléaire puis Xavier piazic
président du directoire de RTE réseau de
transport d'électricité sur le passage
de l'hiver pour le réseau électrique et
puis enfin Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
mercredi 21 septembre la semaine
prochaine nous allons organiser une
table ronde sur les prix de l'énergie
avec plusieurs économistes que nous
allons inviter et ce sera d'ailleurs en
visioconférence puisque ce sera une
réunion mixte
comme j'ai déjà précisé ce cycle
d'audition il va permettre d'une part de
poser le diagnostic sur les raisons qui
ont conduit à l'arrêt de plus de la
moitié des réacteurs du parc nucléaire
sur les responsabilités en ce domaine et
sur les moyens de relancer au plus vite
la production il donnera aussi
l'occasion d'étudier les scénarios de
consommation et de production les
scénarios les plus optimistes comme les
scénarios les plus sombres des mois à
venir et d'élaborer des solutions
concrètes pour que collectivement nous
puissions surmonter les preuves
énergétique
madame la ministre votre intervention
elle se situe à la confluence donc de
deux cycles d'audition menées par la
Commission à cette rentrée et pour ce
qui vous concerne il est évident que les
actions que vous avez engagées et que
vous poursuivez dans les dans les
prochains mois vise à maintenir une
offre énergétique qui est adaptée au
niveau de consommation tout en veillant
à ce que les prix du gaz et
l'électricité à la fois demeure à des
niveaux supportables pour les
particuliers et les entreprises et
fournissent des signaux pertinents pour
orienter nos comportements et notre
économie dans la voie qui permet
d'effectuer la transition énergétique et
indispensable pour faire face aux
problèmes primordial que constitue le
changement climatique
alors je précise ça sera un propos plus
politique que en cette période de crise
énergétique la critique systématique et
le Yaka faucon je crois que c'est assez
pas vraiment le débat public et quand ce
domaine toute la classe politique
on va commencer on met les pieds dans le
plat monsieur jumelles
mais vous allez voir il y en a pour tout
le monde mais en ce domaine en ce
domaine monsieur jumelles toute la
classe politique toutes doit faire son
examen de conscience et remettre les
choses en perspective
et donc on va commencer par soi-même on
va commencer par soi-même du côté de la
majorité
attendez attendez attendez
du côté de la majorité la fermeture de
Fessenheim aurait-elle pu être repoussée
de quelques années peut-être d'un point
de vue technique mais cela aurait-il
changé quoi que ce soit au fait que nous
ayons aujourd'hui 32 réacteurs qui sont
à l'arrêt
pour ce qui concerne je vois que vous
êtes très en forme dans cette rentrée
chers collègues
pour ce qui concerne l'opposition
ce que je viens de parler de l'examen
critique que nous pouvons faire y
compris côté majorité donc pour ce qui
concerne l'opposition les écologistes ne
pourrait-il pas concéder qu'en prenant
partout en Europe une sortie rapide et
totale du nucléaire ils ont placé les
pays et ensuite cette préconisation dans
une situation de dépendance on est aux
énergies fossiles dont nous subissons
aujourd'hui des conséquences
néfastes du côté du RN
vous êtes désormais pro à demander
toujours plus de nucléaires mais si on
se souvient qu'en 2011 votre président
de groupe dénoncé sur France Inter une
énergie je cite énormément dangereuse
dont il fallait sortir
croyez-vous vraiment qu'une telle
position l'aurait pousser à investir
dans de nouveaux réacteurs
quant au républicains qui je le
reconnais ont toujours été pro nucléaire
on a cherché je reconnais la volontiers
puis-je rappeler que le dernier acteur
lancé lorsque vous étiez au pouvoir
c'est comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
le père de Flamanville
l'initiative elle remonte à 2002 et il
n'est toujours pas rentré en fonction et
ce que vous n'auriez pas pu programmer
aussi la construction d'autres réacteurs
dans un secteur où les cycles
d'investissement sont longs dans les dix
années suivantes vous détaillez le
pouvoir
par ailleurs et là c'est l'ancien c'est
l'ancien rapporteur de la loi zap qui
s'exprime votre groupe n'a-t-il pas
constamment cherché à freiner le
développement des renouvelables
notamment sur l'éolien offshore c'était
un des motifs de refus de la loi Asa
pour certains collègues
donc en ce mois de septembre
acceptons acceptons collectivement de
faire preuve d'un peu d'humidité plutôt
que de donner des leçons madame la
ministre vous allez pouvoir nous exposer
votre politique dans votre intervention
luminaire d'une durée de 15 à 20 minutes
je rappelle que les orateurs de groupe
disposeront d'un temps global de 4
minutes pour vous interroger tant qu'il
inclut la réponse que vous fournirez je
précise à cet égard que par le respect
pour nos invités le bureau de la
commission réunit ce jour même à
autorisé le président a interrompre un
orateur qui viendrait à dépasser 3
minutes d'intervention afin de laisser à
la personne auditionnée un minimum de
temps pour ça réponse et donc après
cette introduction non il y a pas de
rappel au règlement en commission
monsieur jumelle
non mais on n'est pas en hémicycle
madame la ministre vous avez donc la
parole
merci monsieur le Président merci pour
cette introduction tonique qui permet de
mettre chacun dans une bonne posture
d'écoute
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
vous remercie de l'organisation de cette
audition sur les priorités non ministère
en matière de politique énergétique et
qui vont rejoindre aussi les travaux que
vous allez mener sur la politique
énergétique et vous le savez il y aura
un débat qui sera organisé à l'Assemblée
nationale comme il le sera au Sénat sur
la politique énergétique dans les
prochaines semaines qui sera calée en
amont de l'examen du projet de loi
accélération des énergies renouvelables
donc ça c'est pour le programme qui va
nous réunir prochainement nous vivons un
moment singulier qui nous impose de
revoir nos modes d'action en profondeur
avec une double temporalité l'urgence de
l'hiver prochain et nos objectifs de
neutralité carbone d'ici 2050
paradoxalement c'est bien ce dernier
objectif de neutralité carbone qui revêt
le plus grand caractère d'urgence la
politique énergétique c'est une vision
stratégique de long terme vous l'avez
d'ailleurs rappelé par rapport au
nucléaire ce sont des décisions qui en
fait impactent sur des dizaines d'années
et
c'est un enjeu éminemment géopolitique
et je crois que les événements en
Ukraine et en Russie se chargent de nous
le rappeler quotidiennement nos
décisions d'aujourd'hui sont donc celles
qui vont conditionner notre indépendance
et notre souveraineté énergétique de
demain j'y reviendrai l'état des lieux
je crois qu'il est clair et assez
largement partagé le sixième rapport
d'évaluation du GIEC nous alerte sur la
nécessité de prendre des actions rapides
et à grande échelle pour limiter le
réchauffement climatique les scénarios
qui prévoit de limiter le réchauffement
à un degré 5 implique que les émissions
mondiales de gaz à effet de serre
atteignent un pic au plus tard en 2025
qui disent qu'elle avait pas de peigne
applique veut donc dire ensuite elle
diminue et de 2025 c'est maintenant
l'été que nous venons de traverser nous
a fait une démonstration concrète du
démon réglement climatique au travers
des différents épisodes de canicule
d'incendie d'assèchement de nappe
phréatique et au fond le réchauffement
climatique n'est plus une abstraction
pour un pays tempéré comme la France il
est entré dans la vie quotidienne des
Français avec les conséquences que nous
connaissons sur la fonte de nos glaciers
les épisodes de gel de canicule de plus
abondante qui fragilise notre
agriculture ou dans un autre registre la
disparition d'une partie de notre
biodiversité ces phénomènes nous le
savons sont la conséquence de l'activité
humaine nous vivons en même temps un
bouleversement de l'ordre mondial la
guerre en Ukraine et ses conséquences
géopolitiques ont perturbé des circuits
d'approvisionnement des produits
énergétiques fossiles pétroliers et de
gaz naturel je rappelle que la Russie
c'est grosso modo 40% de fournitures du
gaz européen 17% pour la France mais 40%
pour l'ensemble
de l'Union européenne et c'est près de
50% de la fourniture du diesel avant la
crise ukrainienne et à peu près 20% pour
20-25% pour la France
cette crise a rappelé la dépendance de
notre économie nos modes de vie aux
énergies fossiles importées de la même
manière que la crise de la covid nous
avait rappelé notre dépendance à des
productions industrielles stratégiques
et parfois faible valeur ajoutée
produite à plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres de nos frontières les
Français subissent directement les
conséquences de cette situation sur leur
pouvoir d'achat l'augmentation des prix
d'énergie représente 60% de l'inflation
en dépit du blocage des prix du gaz et
de l'électricité des mesures carburants
que nous avons mis en place ce sont
également les entreprises et ce sont
d'ailleurs surtout les entreprises et
les collectivités locales qui subissent
à différents degrés ces augmentations
le gouvernement a pris des mesures
massives pour limiter ses os notre
priorité vous le savez c'est de tout
faire pour protéger les Français je
rappelle que le coût des boucliers
tarifaires et des mesures carburants ce
chiffre à plus de 20 milliards d'euros
c'est sans aucun équivalent en Europe et
plus largement dans le monde et il y a
une étude récente économique qui est
effectivement fait de la France le pays
où le bouclier énergétique a été mis en
place le plus rapidement et avec le plus
d'impact pour les ménages j'insiste sur
ce point là pour les ménages et les très
petites entreprises s'agissant
d'électricité face à cette situation la
feuille de route d'action de mon
ministère et donc claire et répond aux
exigences de cette double temporalité
que j'évoquais plutôt
j'ai lancé dès mon arrivée plusieurs
grands chantiers le premier c'est celui
de la préparation
de la
de l'hiver et plus largement le fait de
d'aider notre pays à se passer des
importations du gaz et du pétrole russe
dans ce contexte un certain imprévisible
notre responsabilité d'anticiper tous
les risques nous y travaillons depuis
plusieurs mois et donc nous travaillons
sur un scénario du pire car il existe je
l'ai dit devant vous cet été lors de
l'audition sur le projet de loi sur les
mesures pour le pouvoir d'achat nous
sommes dans une course contre la montre
que nous avons anticipé préparer depuis
plusieurs mois nous avons sécurisé nos
stocks stratégiques de gaz nous avons
deux mois d'avance en termes de
remplissage de nos stocks stratégiques
de gaz
nous avons également travaillé sur notre
consommation d'énergie l'objectif est
dans de réduire cette consommation en
particulier de gaz
c'est pourquoi je me réjouis du vote des
mesures du projet de loi pouvoir d'achat
ces mesures donnent des leviers
essentiels à l'état pour sécurité nos
stocks d'énergie le remplissage je l'ai
dit la mise en place du régime
d'effacement sur le réseau électrique la
réquisition de centrales à gaz la
prolongation de la centrale de
Saint-Avold qui est d'un point de vue
climatique pas une bonne nouvelle
personne n'en dit ce qu'on vient et je
vais pas vous dire le contraire mais qui
est un point de vue de sécurité de notre
alimentation électrique un levier parmi
les autres que nous mobilisons et je
rappelle qu'il s'agit d'un pour cent de
notre production électrique donc ça fait
partie des leviers et enfin le démarrage
du projet de terminal métallier au port
du Havre pour lequel nous avions pris
des mesures de sécurisation mais dont
nous n'aurons pas à usé finalement
puisque
les enquêtes environnementales ne
témoignent pas de difficultés
particulières
nous avons également engagé la
diversification de nos
approvisionnements si bien que nous
avons réduit la part d'importation de
gaz russe de 17% en 2020 à environ 7 9%
actuellement et nous poursuivons ce
travail géant parallèle pris des mesures
réglementaires pour débloquer des
projets d'énergie renouvelables qui
étaient à rapidement mobilisable et qui
représente un potentiel de 6 à 7
gigawatts de projets solaires 5 et 6
gigawatts de projet et éolien et j'ai
fait de même avec le biogaz le
fonctionnement de notre parc nucléaire
s'est hiver sera également déterminant
dans notre capacité à répondre aux
possibles pics de consommation qui sont
liés au caractère aléatoire de la météo
vous le savez actuellement 31 réacteurs
nucléaires sur 52 sont à l'arrêts ça
varie d'un jour sur l'autre mais on est
en grosso modo dans dans cette épure à
la fois en raison de maintenance
programmer et pour 12 d'entre eux pour
des problématiques de corrosion sous
contrainte c'est pourquoi nous attendons
d'EDF le respect de son calendrier de
maintenance ce calendrier vous le savez
il est indiquer publiquement sur parce
que ça fait partie d'un texte de loi une
directive européenne qui exige que tous
les producteurs soient transparents sur
leur site de production démarrage et
arrêt et ce sera une des priorités de la
nouvelle direction d'EDF que de
s'assurer de la bonne tenue de ce de ce
calendrier et de la prise en compte des
mesures d'amélioration
de de la tenue des maintenances dans les
mois qui viennent le second levier vous
le savez c'est celui de la sobriété
énergétique qui nous a conduit à porter
un plan un plan de sobriété annoncé par
la première ministre et président de la
République avant l'été avec l'objectif
de réduire notre consommation d'énergie
de 10% d'ici deux ans c'est la première
marche du plan de sobriété que nous
devons mener pour atteindre notre
neutralité carbone à horizon 20 donc il
s'agit bien d'un plan structurel il ne
s'agit pas d'un plan conjoncturel et si
tu ne démarche qui a vocation à se
poursuivre au-delà des deux années qui
viennent pour pouvoir durablement
accompagner le changement de nos
habitudes de travail c'est un plan qui
mobilise en premier lieu les grands
acteurs ceux qui ont la plus grande
capacité à obtenir des résultats parce
qu'ils ont des moyens et parce qu'ils
gèrent des millions de mètres carrés de
bâtiments et parce qu'ils sont aussi à
l'origine du déplacement de millions de
personnes soit dans le cadre
professionnel par dans le cadre de la
vie professionnelle soit par les
déplacements domicile travail et donc
nous avons mis en jeu 9 groupes de
travail sectoriels qui réunissent non
seulement l'administration et l'État qui
devra être exemplaire en la matière et
nous sommes conscients qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire mais
également l'ensemble des grosses des
grandes entreprises et des secteurs pour
parvenir à diminuer
structurellement leur manière de
chauffer d'utiliser l'eau chaude
sanitaire de se déplacer d'utiliser les
véhicules de société je vais pas rentrer
dans le détail ce plan c'est aussi un
plan qui est construit par les acteurs
sur le terrain et qui a vocation à
remonter au niveau de l'État mais ce
n'est pas le l'État qui va fixer les
températures
de
chauffage de l'eau chaude sanitaire ou
dans d'autres domaines il existe déjà
des textes qui sont clairs mais un
certain nombre d'éléments dépendent de
l'organisation du travail de tous les
jours de chaque entreprise et de chaque
administration
enfin une mise au point au regard de ce
que j'ai pu entendre ici et là je ne
dérogerai pas un principe il ne s'agit
pas de demander aux 12 millions de
Français en situation de précarité
énergétique de faire des efforts de
sobriété la sobriété la subisse au
quotidien ils sont pas ceux à qui il
faut faire il faut demander de faire des
efforts c'est une question de justice
sociale et bien au contraire une des
premières mesures que j'ai prise
également à viser à mettre en place un
plan d'accompagnement des plus précaires
pour que eux puissent sortir de ces
situations et
pouvoir
vivre dans des conditions dignes et
notamment des conditions dignes de
chauffage parce que c'est souvent cette
situation qui est en cause et donc nous
avons mobilisé 150 millions d'euros de
d'équivalent
ces deux œufs sur ce sujet là avant
l'été
qui est juste l'accompagnement cela
s'est accumule enfin cela s'ajoute à
toutes les mesures d'accompagnement
financière donc il s'agit pas d'une
mesure à 150 millions d'euros c'est 150
millions additionnels pour les acteurs
qui accompagnent les personnes en
situation précaire j'ai également
demandé aux énergéticiens de s'engager
en proposant en français et aux
entreprises des contrats qui valorisent
leur effort de sobriété et leur
permettre de faire des contreparties en
contrepartie de leur effort tarif à
pointe mobile incitation à mieux piloter
sa consommation à distance beaucoup peut
être fait deuxième élément nous
engageons les grandes transformations
nécessaires pour accélérer la sortie des
énergies fossiles et renforcer notre
souveraineté énergétique la production
massive d'énergie des carbonées est
déterminante pour notre souveraineté
pour notre indépendance énergétique elle
est notre levier pour sortir de notre
dépendance mortifère aux énergies
fossiles nous devons donc être en mesure
de produire 60% d'électricité plus
qu'aujourd'hui pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2050 vous l'avez
compris je me fonde sur les scénarios
RTE qui publié en 2021
le rapport RTE indique nous pouvons y
parvenir nous appuyant sur un mix
décarboné équilibré reposant sur
l'énergie nucléaire et le développement
massif d'énergie renouvelable c'est le
choix écologique le plus pertinent le
choix économique le plus opportun le
choix financier le moins coûteux c'est
les conclusions du rapport sur les
différents jeux de scénarios préparés
présentés par RTE la transition commence
dès aujourd'hui avec le développement
massif des énergies renouvelables le
président de la République a fixé des
objectifs ambitieux sur notre production
d'énergie solaire multiplication par 10
ou sur le développement de parcs éolien
marin d'ici 2050 ce développement
s'inscrit dans une volonté d'associer
les filières industrielles françaises
existantes et dans bâtir de nouvelles
grâce au plan France 2030 nous le voyons
la France accuse un retard dans le
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
par rapport aux autres pays européens
elle ne l'est pas en retard faute de
projet
elle est en raison de nos procédures
administratives et contentieuses il faut
en moyenne 5 ans de procédures pour
construire un parc solaire nécessitant
quelques mois de travaux
ces temps pour un parc éolien et près de
10 ans pour un parc éolien en mer ce qui
explique que la France possède seulement
un parquet éolien en mer en
fonctionnement à l'heure de la crise
climatique de la crise géopolitique de
la crise énergétique comment l'accepter
il est intéressant de voir d'ailleurs
que nos voisins ont pris les taureaux le
taureau par les cornes j'ai changé avec
un de mes homologues allemands hier qui
m'indiquait que sur l'éolien ils sont
aujourd'hui passés de 7 ans à 7 mois
nous devons donc aller plus vite en
levant les barrières réglementaires sans
renier nos exigences environnementales
nous devons aller plus vite et créer les
conditions de l'acceptabilité locale de
ces projets qui sera déterminant dans
leur réussite et dans le développement
des suivants sur d'autres territoires
nous devons le faire avec des
territoires et non contre eux en leur
redonnant les leviers de la politique
énergétique territoriale ça sera l'objet
du projet de loi d'accélération sur la
le projet de loi sur l'accélération du
développement des énergies renouvelables
qui s'inscrit dans un plan énergies
renouvelable plus large vous l'avez
compris ce plan comprend des leviers
administratifs dans le je dirais le
fonctionnement courant de l'état nous
allons envoyer une circulaire au préfet
en ce sens pour aider notamment à
accompagner les collectivités locales la
cartographie les endroits qui sont les
plus propices en installation d'énergie
renouvelables et puis pour débloquer les
projets au fur et à mesure c'est
également un renforcement des équipes
qui est nécessaire au niveau de
l'instruction des dreads ça nous a été
très clairement remontée par beaucoup
d'entre vous ce sont enfin des mesures
réglementaires j'en ai cité un certain
nombre autour du biogaz du
photovoltaïques et de lait au lien
terrestre le projet de loi sur
l'accélération du développement des
énergies renouvelables qui vous a déjà
été transmis cet été dans une version
qui n'a pas encore été transmise au
Conseil des ministres et qui seront donc
appelé à être modifié puisque nous
tenons compte du retour des
concertations diverses que nous faisons
répond à ces impératifs majeurs c'est un
texte en faveur de l'indépendance de la
souveraineté énergétique de notre nation
c'est un texte qui nous met en ligne
avec nos objectifs de neutralité carbone
et nous allons le mener dans un esprit
de dialogue et de concertation pour cela
je compte sur vous car j'en entends
beaucoup sur ces mots parler de
souveraineté
beaucoup aussi parler de la nécessité de
faire face au réchauffement climatique
c'est donc l'occasion pour chacun de
prendre ses responsabilités la France a
fait le choix historique et audacieux
dans les années 70 de développer aussi
un parc nucléaire qui concourt à notre
indépendance énergétique à la limitation
des gaz à effet de serre et à
l'attractivité de notre territoire je
rappelle que nous sommes un des pays qui
disposent d'un mix électrique les plus
décarbonées du monde et que notre enjeu
est d'avoir un mix énergétique
c'est-à-dire sur la partie chaleur et
déplacement qui soit assez niveau de
décarbonation et donc l'enjeu n'est pas
d'opposé énergie renouvelable et
nucléaire mais de savoir comment on sait
se passer du carburant du gaz du charbon
et de tout autre énergie fossile
parallèlement à l'essor des énergies
renouvelables nous faisons donc le choix
de réaffirmer la place centrale et
stratégique de la technologie nucléaire
pour réussir notre transition
énergétique à Belfort le président de la
République a annoncé des investissements
massifs dans notre parc nucléaire avec
le lancement d'un programme de 6 EPR 2
le lancement d'études pour la
construction de 8 PA2 un milliard
d'euros du plan France 2030 sont
également consacrés au développement de
petits réacteurs et ses mers et vous le
savez le plan de relance avait déjà
consacré une somme importante au secteur
nucléaire en faisant un des 6 secteurs
prioritaires de notre politique
industrielle
de plus tous les réacteurs pouvant être
prolongés dans des conditions de
sécurité exigeantes évidemment le seront
un projet de loi sur le nucléaire
introduira des dispositions pour gagner
du temps de procédure sur le lancement
des chantiers c'est probablement un
texte de début 2023 l'opération de
monter à 100% du capital que nous
mentons sur EDF et stratégique dans
notre stratégies de déploiement
d'énergie décarbonée cette montée à 100%
du capital réaffirme notre engagement à
soutenir l'entreprise dans la durée pour
réussir les défis de la transition
énergétique la poursuite du déploiement
des énergies renouvelables en France une
maintient du parc actuel et du prochain
programme de PR2
ces différentes questions sur notre
choix en matière de mix énergétique
seront au cœur de la concertation
nationale que nous tiendrons à partir
d'octobre c'est la stratégie française
énergies climat qui donne lieu à un
débat public qui se déroulera d'octobre
à janvier prochain cette concertation se
tiendra dans chaque territoire en y
associe en les citoyens les associations
les élus et les entreprises ce sera un
moment démocratique important qui vise à
ce que chaque citoyen s'approprie leur
avenir énergétique et qui se vous sera
soumise sous forme de texte loi énergie
climat au deuxième semestre 2023
le développement massif de nos énergies
décarbonées doit être aussi et nucléaire
doit être un moteur pour notre économie
et nos emplois c'est le troisième axe
c'est celui de développer une politique
industrielle de l'énergie je vais pas
revenir sur les politiques qui ont été
engagées sur l'hydrogène et jikafactory
de batterie électrique les flotteurs
éoliens ou encore le nouveau nucléaire
il y a clairement des angles morts je
pensais aux photosvoltaïques ces
investissements ils doivent aujourd'hui
être portés dans le cas notamment de
France 2030 et il suppose d'avoir aussi
la compétitivité sur nos territoires
donc c'est un sujet qu'on doit suivre
avec beaucoup d'attention puisqu'il y a
d'autres facteurs qui expliquent que des
entreprises décident de construire en
France plutôt qu'ailleurs nous
poursuivrons également la décarbonation
du secteur industriel puisque c'est un
levier de compétitivité pour nos
entreprises c'est aussi un levier de
pérennité dans la durée vous savez que
nous consacrons 7 milliards d'euros à
cette à cette stratégie
je suis convaincue que les décisions
européennes extrêmement ambitieuses du
paquet climat fit for fifty-five adopté
ce président français de l'Union
européenne et grâce à l'insulsion du
président de la République amorce les
grandes transformations nécessaires pour
préparer l'ensemble de notre modèle
économique je ne reviendrai pas sur les
enjeux de composants critiques sur les
enjeux de métaux critiques vous
connaissez tout cela il s'agit aussi de
ne pas créer de nouvelles dépendances
après être sortie des dépendances
fossiles enfin pour conclure parce que
j'ai été très longue
je
mentionnerai rapidement le quatrième
aspect de ma feuille de route c'est
notre action au plan diplomatique au
niveau européen comme international ça
va être un enjeu notamment de la COP 27
qui se tiendra à sharm-elcher pas
forcément dans les conditions de je
dirais d'enthousiasme et de d'énergie
qu'on aurait pu souhaiter donc elle
conviendra d'être au rendez-vous pour
créer les alliances qui permettront de
continuer ce combat sur la lutte contre
le réchauffement clim et vous le savez
je porte à Bruxelles la position
française au Conseil des ministres de
l'énergie ça a été le cas vendredi
dernier avec plusieurs mentions d'abord
comment limiter la spéculation sur le
marché de l'électricité et du gaz
plafonner le prix du gaz mettre en place
une contribution sur ce qu'on appelle
les profits infra marginaux c'est-à-dire
l'écart entre les prix du marché et les
coûts de production d'un certain nombre
d'énergéticiens et enfin tout le travail
que nous menons à plus long terme sur la
réforme du marché de l'électricité
beaucoup sur ses bancs soutiennent cette
démarche que nous conduisons au niveau
de l'Europe et sur lequel nous
commençons à avoir un soutien plus large
au niveau européen je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre nous allons
donner la parole aux orateurs des
différents groupes politiques pour 4
minutes madame la ministre je précise
que c'est 4 minutes réponse compris
c'est à dire qu'à l'orateur vous
interroge et que à 4 minutes je coupe
vraiment le son donc
on commence tout de suite par Charles
Rodwell du groupe Renaissance merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
merci d'avoir accepté de participer à
cette audition consacrer la hausse des
prix de l'énergie la France est l'un des
pays au monde qui a le mieux protégé ces
ménages et ses entreprises par les
mesures que nous avons mises en œuvre
nous avons évité une explosion des prix
de l'énergie de l'ordre de 50 à 70 % la
crise énergétique a néanmoins des
conséquences majeures sur le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages sur la compétitivité
des entreprises et cela richesse de
notre pays un indicateur clé notre
balance commerciale la hausse des prix
de l'énergie a fortement creusé notre
déficit commercial qui atteint au
premier semestre 71 milliards d'euros
dans ce contexte la France doit relancer
au plus vite sa production d'origine
nucléaire et développer rapidement des
sources alternatives d'électricité
c'est le sens des annonces du président
de la République sur la construction de
nouveaux EPR et du projet loi
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables qui sera présentée cet
automne au Parlement
madame la ministre notre majorité a fait
de la protection du pouvoir d'achat des
Français une priorité absolue de son
action du rétablissement notre balance
commerciale le défi économique de la
France pour les années qui viennent et
de la transition énergétique l'enjeu
majeur de cette Destinie aussi dans le
champ d'action qui le vôtre je souhaite
vous poser au nom de mon groupe trois
questions à quel horizon peut-on prévoir
d'atteindre le mix nucléaire ENR que
vous proposez
de comment réformer le marché européen
de l'énergie pour contribuer à cet
objectif et 3 confirmez-vous que la
Renaissance d'EDF s'inscrit dans une
stratégie de long terme dans laquelle
l'État dispose de tous les leviers pour
réorganiser notre filière nucléaire je
vous remercie
madame la ministre
c'est très court oui sur la troisième
question
c'est à dire que évidemment c'est une
action de long terme qui vise à pouvoir
redonner à EDF la capacité enfin à nous
redonner en tant que état la capacité à
faire de DF le bras armé notre politique
énergétique et avec un plan très clair
sur la réforme du marché européen
l'objectif et vous avez probablement
entendu le chancelier Scholl ce qui est
également réclame une réforme rapide du
marché
européen l'idée est d'avoir un prix
d'électricité qui soit plus proche de la
base d'actifs sur lequel enfin à partir
desquels l'électricité est produite donc
un lien pour le consommateur entre le
prix qu'il paye et la réalité
des centrales qui produisent
l'électricité dont il bénéficie et de
pouvoir déconnecter le prix
l'électricité de celui le gaz dès lors
que le gaz n'est pas un des une des
énergies les plus utilisées dans notre
mix énergétique et deuxièmement de ne
pas payer le prix du carbone alors qu'on
a une électricité déjà décarbonée en
tout cas de ne payer le que le juste
prix du carbone donc c'est les pistes ce
n'est pas c'est une réforme qui vise en
fait à mieux refléter le prix pour le
consommateur
sur le passage de l'hiver peut-être très
rapidement un premier point
notre les opérateurs de réseau
présent avec deux mois d'avance un point
de situation demain sur leur vision du
passage de divers je pense que c'est
très important d'avoir le plus tôt
possible cette vision des experts de
façon à bien préciser qu'elle est à la
fois la réalité des risques mais
également les le fait que ces risques ne
sont pas dimensionnés comme peut-être le
marché semble nous les indiquer on le
voit dans le et nous avons toute une
série de leviers que j'ai mentionnées à
la fois de constitution de stocks
d'anticipation de production
complémentaire d'électricité de
mécanisme de réduction de notre
consommation volontaire ou plus
accompagné interruptibilité
effacement et les leviers de plantes
continuité classique sur lequel je
pourrais revenir merci madame la
ministre monsieur Grégoire de Fournas
pour le groupe rassemblement national
fort de ce désastre aucun regret aucune
excuse mais seulement la décence de
chercher des boucs émissaires ou de
sonner la fin d'une abondance dont les
Français ont déjà fait le deuil depuis
longtemps les Français ne supportent
plus le en même temps du président de la
République il annonce relancer la
construction de centrales nucléaire mais
les textes en vigueur prévoient toujours
la fermeture de 14 réacteurs et le
projet et le prochain projet de loi qui
va être proposé au Parlement n'envisage
pas de corriger cela mais d'accélérer le
développement des énergies renouvelables
et vous l'avez dit à marche forcée des
énergies renouvelables
inefficaces et coûteuses alors que
l'industrie a besoin d'une énergie
fiable et compétitive en un mot vous
avez été ministre de l'Industrie et vous
allez maintenant défendre un texte qui
raconte l'avenir de cette même industrie
par ailleurs vous avez été vous avez été
d'une incohérence hallucinante en
évoquant il y a quelques jours l'impact
très limité sur le climat des jets
privés des footballeurs pour affirmer 5
jours plus tard que le PSG était en
retard sur les questions climatiques
madame la ministre il faut maintenant
une stratégie claire quels moyens
comptez-vous donner à EDF pour relancer
le parc nucléaire que vous avez saboté
quand comptez-vous faire sortir la
France du marché européen de
l'électricité qui fait exploser la
facture d'énergie des français quand
comptez-vous abroger l'absurde de
dispositif à Rennes qui ruine EDF quand
vous mettre fin à la course folle aux
éoliennes polluantes inefficaces et
coûteuse en renonçant notamment à votre
projet scandaleux de suppression des
recours contre les projets éoliens
madame la ministre
monsieur de Fournas outre que vous avez
une qualité
remarquable qui est de refaire le monde
et réécrire l'histoire je rappelle les
propos de Marine Le Pen qui mettaient en
cause c'était tergies extraordinairement
dangereuse qui était le nucléaire donc
ayez au moins la
ici et malheureusement il y a non
seulement des écrits mais il y a des
oraux et je crois qu'on les a tous
partagés sur ces bancs alors
probablement pas les personnes de votre
groupe mais les autres étaient présents
ils ont des yeux ils ont des oreilles
donc ça c'est le premier point et
effectivement cette stratégie qui
consiste à aller dans le sens du vent
elle est pratique parce qu'en règle
générale on ne se trompe pas souvent
s'agissant du nucléaire j'ai le regret
de vous dire de manière très claire
d'une part que ces Emmanuel Macron
président de la République qui a procédé
au sauvetage d'Areva et qui a permis de
sécuriser Orano et de sécuriser la
filière industrielle nucléaire que c'est
le même Emmanuel Macron
en 2020 fait dans le plan de relance
c'était il y a deux ans du secteur
nucléaire une des six priorités
industrielles de ce pays que c'est lui
qui en fait une des priorités de plan
France 2030 que c'est lui qui passe
commande des scénarios RTE dont certains
vont dire qu'ils nous correspondent pas
à leur vision mais en toute cause qui
explicite l'importance du nucléaire dans
notre mix énergétique si on veut
effectivement avoir un je dirais un
résultat économique probants et que
c'est encore lui qui lance le programme
de 6 EPR nouveau alors même que
Flamanville n'est pas livré alors que
l'idée était que femme en ville soit
livré et
merci beaucoup madame la ministre on va
passer à l'orateur suivant monsieur
Tavel groupe la France insoumise
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous avez fait un long
développement mais il y a quand même
quelques silences vous parlez de
sobriété mais seulement 2500 logements
ont cessé d'être des passoires
thermiques en 2021 à ce rythme là nous
serons loin de la sobriété indispensable
vous parlez des scénarios de RTE mais
vous oubliez de mentionner un scénario
qui évoque 100% d'énergie renouvelable
et qui fait la démonstration de la
faisabilité d'un tel scénario vous
parlez de la dépendance au métaux rares
mais comme par hasard la dépendance à
l'uranium elle vous ne l'évoquez pas
première question à quoi sert cet
assemblée puisque tout semble se décider
désormais dans un conseil de défense
énergétique à huis clos sous secret
défense dont on ne sait rien puisque
vous êtes là mais c'est demain que la
première ministre fera ses annonces sur
l'énergie en gros êtes-vous là madame
pour nous parler de choses que vous ne
savez pas que la première ministre dira
demain où êtes-vous là pour ne pas nous
parler des choses que vous savez elle
dira demain mais dans tous les cas
permettez-nous au moins de poser ces
questions clairement à quoi sert cette
commission ou a lieu le débat public sur
l'énergie dans notre pays est-ce dans le
conseil de défense ou est-ce au
Parlement des questions claires pourtant
Gabriel Attal porte-parole du
gouvernement dit qu'il y aura des
hausses des prix de l'énergie combien
pour qui pourquoi voilà les questions
qui se posent car si on regarde les
coûts de production de l'électricité
dans notre pays ils n'ont augmenté l'an
dernier que de 4%. ce qui a explosé ce
ne sont pas les coûts de production de
l'électricité ce sont les surcoûts les
gaspillages les pillages du marché de
l'électricité et donc la question est
très claire puisque le marché européen
est un échec puisque il ne règle pas la
question des prix bas puisque il n'a pas
permis le développement des énergies
renouvelables puisque le gouvernement
auquel vous appartenez a été le moins
performant en Europe à ce sujet
puisqu'il ne permet pas le blackout et
même les rationnements que vous nous
évoquez maintenant puisque le marché
européen n'est pas indispensable à
l'interconnexion qui existait bien avant
entre les pays européens bien avant le
marché de l'énergie pourquoi garder ce
marché pourquoi rester dans ce
système-là pourquoi ne pas revenir à un
tarif régulé pour tous les acteurs
particuliers entreprises collectivités
locales qui soient fondées simplement
sur le coût de production réelle de
l'énergie et non pas sur les surcoûts du
marché madame la ministre
ok
beaucoup de questions dans votre
question alors de quoi discutons-nous de
la politique énergétique et de ma
feuille de route sur ces cinq dernières
années je ne crois pas que ce soit
l'intervention de la première ministre
de rentrer dans le détail de ce débat
demain ça c'est le premier point
s'agissant de notre dépendance à par
exemple uranium je me permets de
rappeler que la France dispose d'un
approvisionnement diversifié en uranium
naturel et qu'elle dépend et qu'elle
dispose de l'ensemble de la maîtrise
technologique de toute la le cycle
d'enrichissement du combustible
contrairement à ce que certains membres
affiliés à la nups on dit sur les
plateaux de télévision en manifestants
manifestement une grande méconnaissance
du secteur du nucléaire
s'agissant ensuite du prix d'électricité
il est quand même utile de rappeler
combien paye les Français les Français
ont effectivement connu en 2022 une
augmentation de 4% des prix de
l'électricité
c'est le prix le plus bas de toute
l'Europe et quand j'entends également
vos compares ce comment dire si mouvoir
du fait que le Royaume-Uni bloque le
prix l'électricité après que ce prix est
fait X2 ou X3 et que les niveaux
d'inflation au Royaume-Uni soit
largement supérieur à celui de l'Europe
je m'étonne que vous n'applaudissiez pas
dès demain la politique de blocage des
prix que nous avons mené en France donc
je crois que de ce point de vue là on
n'a pas à rougir de ce qui a été fait et
de la protection des Français la
protection des Français vous n'en avez
pas le monopole heureusement que nous
étions là pour le faire merci Madame la
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur Julien
dive du groupe les républicain c'est à
vous
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre pour commencer monsieur le
Président je vais vous répondre vous
avez commencé votre introduction en
faisant l'inventaire de l'historique de
chaque groupe politique et pour les
républicains vous avez fort justement
rappelé que nous soutenions depuis très
longtemps la question du nucléaire mais
vous avez émis un mensonge en précisant
que les républicains lorsqu'ils étaient
au responsabilités n'ont rien mené sur
le nucléaire c'est faux puisqu'en 2020
en 2006 sous les JIT du président Chirac
le président Astrid de quatrième
génération générateur a été lancée
renforcé par le président Sarkozy et
abandonné par le président Emmanuel
Macron en 2019 vous voyez dans les faits
nous avons été au rendez-vous du
nucléaire puisqu'en plus il s'agissait
d'un projet qui permettait de recycler
les déchets nucléaires et d'en réduire
considérablement maintenant pour revenir
au sujet et l'audition de de Madame la
Ministre Nam la ministre le 29 juin 2020
à 23h ce n'est le glas du deuxième
réacteur de la centrale de FaceTime
après 43 ans de service était donc fin
de service de cette centrale nucléaire
qui quelque part a mis en difficulté ça
a été rappelé sur les différents bancs
la souveraineté énergétique de la France
il y avait un argument qui était opposé
à l'époque par les gouvernements qui
étaient d'accélérer la transition
énergétique pour pour
l'avenir madame la ministre pouvez-vous
nous indiquer quels sont les parts
d'énergie renouvelable qui ont été qui
ont permis de remplacer justement la
fermeture de Fessenheim pouvez-vous nous
assurer que cet hiver aucune centrale
nucléaire sera à l'arrêt en France
d'autant plus que nous avions signalé
sur ces bancs mais aussi sur d'autres
bancs je pense au Parlement européen et
à multiples reprises que la fermeture de
Fessenheim mettrait en difficulté la
France mais aussi aurait un impact sur
le coup des français ce qui a mené à la
prison en compte de certaines mesures
c'est vrai mais aujourd'hui les
collectivités les entreprises en paix le
prix fort et pouvez-vous nous indiquer
quels sont les freins que vous avez
identifié à la transition
merci Monsieur dive je note la grande
humilité de vos propos sur tout ce qui a
été très bien fait jusqu'à présent de
votre côté madame la ministre
alors peut-être juste pour préciser une
chose sur le projet Astrid parce que je
voudrais pas que ce soit mis en rapport
de la crise énergétique actuelle le
projet Astrid comme vous le savez c'est
une technologie qui dépassait très
largement 2050 et dont la maturité était
attendue pour 2100 donc ce en terme de
comment dire maturité du projet on
n'était pas exactement dans les pures de
la crise énergétique auxquels nous
faisons face aujourd'hui je tiens à le
préciser
s'agissant de votre question sur les
freins à la transition énergétique vous
les connaissez
vous les connaissez ils sont de
différents ordres le premier frein à la
transition énergétique c'est notre
capacité à délivrer rapidement des
projets réducteurs de carbone ces
projets supposent un certain de
mobiliser un certain nombre de
procédures administratives et ce cadre
qui parfois s'empile peut singulièrement
compliquer les choses donc si on reprend
nous par exemple sur la question des
énergies renouvelables et c'est le sujet
que nous avons très précisément analysé
il y a il faut balayer devant notre
porte quelle instruction nous donnons à
nos préfets et qu'elle est la
priorisation que nous donnons pour
accélérer les projets en question
première élément deuxième élément a-t-on
les équipes disponibles pour instruire
les projets en question il y a un
problème de renforcement des équipes
c'est quelque chose qui revient
troisièmement est-ce que nous avons la
bonne concertation avec les élus et là
les préfets ont également probablement
un rôle à jouer mais c'est aussi au
travers des stradettes que cette
concertation peut avoir lieu et les
stradettes la région c'est peut-être un
peu trop gros et il faut penser à une
déclinaison tout en évitant de tomber
dans la contractualisation et le énième
schéma directeur donc vous voyez mon
point voilà éviter les usines à gaz
comme le dit joliment monsieur jumelles
quatrième élément
est-ce que on a également les conditions
économiques pour la réalisation de ces
projets je donne un exemple nous avons
débloqué des projets pour des raisons
d'augmentation de l'inflation ces
projets étaient bloqués donc vous voyez
c'est multi factoriels ça c'est sur les
énergies renouvelables à décarbonation
générale c'est beaucoup plus complexe
une rénovation thermique les transports
l'industrie pour y revenir merci Madame
la Ministre la parole est à Louise Morel
côté modem
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
madame la ministre chers collègues au
nom du groupe démocrate je tiens à
saluer votre fort engagement dans la
gestion de cette crise énergétique crise
qui interroge et qui souvent inquiète
nos concitoyens il y a de très fortes
inquiétudes en ce moment en
circonscription concernant l'hiver à
venir sur nos capacités de production
énergétique et sur le coup de cette
énergie ces inquiétudes elles soulève
Paris Cochet de nombreuses
interrogations sur la possibilité de
recruter de maintenir des équipes de
réaliser des investissements alors nous
saisissons madame la ministre et je
tiens à vous le dire la mesure des
enjeux géopolitiques et géostratégiques
liées à la crise énergétique actuelle
pour autant nos concitoyens ont besoin
impérieux de planification et de
clarification ma question est la
suivante à moyen terme en quoi les
discussions auxquelles vous participez
activement en ce moment à Bruxelles
auront-elles au sujet de la fixation par
nom d'une limite haute du prix du gaz
s'agissant de la fixation du bris du gaz
vous savez que la France est favorable à
une un plafonnement du prix du gaz qui
permettrait de limiter la
l'emballement des prix du gaz avec
des plateformes d'achat groupé qui
permettrait de regrouper tous les
acheteurs qui sont des opérateurs privés
de façon à éviter des effets d'échelle
de perroquet entre acheteurs et
éventuellement avec des mécanismes qui
évitent d'avoir des rationnements
puisque le risque d'un plafonnement du
prix du gaz sur l'ensemble des
importations c'est que les importateurs
suivent préfèrent choisir d'autres
géographies pour
exporter de leur côté du gaz naturel
liquéfié donc c'est bien ces deux
éléments ce n'est pas un élément qui est
uniquement ciblé sur les gazoducs et
uniquement ciblés sur de la Russie
j’ajoute que j'ai pris l'attache de mon
homologue norvégien puisque c'est un des
fournisseurs importants du gaz en Europe
pour également
l'enjoindre à regarder des contrats qui
soient plus long terme et dans lequel on
puisse revoir le prix de gaz et ne pas
forcément avoir un
référentiel qui soit sur un référentiel
de marché qui nous paraît inadapté à
notre économie s'agissant de la facture
des collectivités locales
nous avons pris un certain nombre de
mesures pour faire en sorte que les
collectivités locales puissent être
protégés alors sur l'électricité elles
sont plus effectives c'est à dire que
les plus petites bénéficient du tarif
régulé vous le savez les plus grosses en
matière d'électricité on fait face en
2022 à une augmentation de 20% qui
aurait été de 40% s'il n'y avait pas eu
la reine ceci étant dit 20% c'est sont
en considérable et on sait que dans la
renégociation des contrats de
fournitures la volatilité actuelle des
prix amène des fournisseurs à offrir des
contrats sur des niveaux de référence
qui sont excessivement élevés c'est pour
ça que nous travaillons au niveau
européen a baissé ça je vais pas revenir
non plus sur toutes les mesures
d'accompagnement le filet de securité de
500 millions d'euros pour les
collectivités locales merci beaucoup
madame Baptiste pour le groupe
socialiste
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre question très précise la
première sur la disposition prévue par
la loi en 2019 qui visait à faciliter et
à accélérer les augmentations de
puissance sur les concessions
hydro-existantes qui sont réalisables
évidemment immédiatement ou très
rapidement et qui serait fort utile dans
la situation que nous connaissons de
tension où chaque mégawatt doit compter
j'ai interrogé à maintes reprises et
vous pour en témoigner ici les
concessionnaires les administrations et
les ministres successives la seule
réponse obtenue les dossiers sont prêts
et sont à l'examen 3 ans ou conviendrez
qu'on peut faire mieux en termes
d'accélération et de simplification
cette inertie est aujourd'hui
dommageable alors que l'on cherche de
nouvelles pistes de production et qu'on
en a sous la main quelle est la
véritable raison de cette inertie s'il
manque des ajustements législatives vous
engagez-vous à les proposer dans le
futur PGL ENR la deuxième question c'est
sur le renvoi des clients de certains
fournisseurs vers EDF
on peut dire qu'il gagne deux fois à la
fois en se sourçant à la reine d'un côté
et par la vente aux meilleures heures de
pointe en ces temps débarrassé de leurs
clients vers EDF comptez-vous laisser
perdurer ce système la troisième sur la
volonté de la Commission de créer une
taxe pour par moyen de pour les moyens
de production allez-vous défendre au
niveau de la France une taxe sur les
entreprises et non sur les moyens de
production prix isolément car cela
serait évidemment très dommageable pour
l'hydroélectricité depuis 2021 pour le
gaz et février 2022 pour l'électricité
les particuliers bénéficient d'un gel de
tarif réglementé le gouvernement avait
alors indiqué que le dispositif serait
couvert par un amortissement lycé dans
le temps de ctrv alors que les deux
dispositifs sont prorogés et que les TRV
doivent disparaître au 1er juillet 2023
comment comptez-vous mettre en œuvre
l'amortissement ou la prise en charge de
du bouclier énergétique envisagez-vous
alors de reporter la suppression des TRV
je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre
alors sur deux minutes pour répondre à
vos questions c'est court sur les
concessions hydrauliques vous savez que
il y a différents sujets il y a le sujet
des porteurs de concession dont le cadre
juridique doit être encore clarifié et
qui ne veulent pas engager
d'investissement sans avoir de la
visibilité sur les coûts échoués ça
c'est le premier point effectivement il
y a des moyens législatifs de répondre à
ce sujet là et
ils ne seront pas nécessairement
examinés dans ce projet de loi mais nous
nous engageons à les regarder peut-être
dans un dans un délai un petit peu
différent sur la question des
fournisseurs
vous savez que
lorsque il y a transfert de clients les
fournisseurs perdent leurs droits à
Rennes qu'ils doivent payer dans
toujours qui doivent payer sur le marché
ces droits à Rennes qui sont indus et
qu'ils ont une sanction une pénalité
financière si le volume de doit à Rennes
qu'ils ont perdu et excessif et que
cette sanction en financière est
importante et c'est d'ailleurs la
politique qu'applique la creux et vous
savez que des enquêtes sont engagées
notamment sur un premier fournisseur qui
est home en énergie j'ai demandé à la
Creuse d'être extraordinairement
vigilante sur l'utilisation des droits
arènes pas tellement sur la répercussion
du prix parce qu'elle est correctement
faite mais effectivement sur les
mouvements de clients entre fournisseurs
privés et souvent retour ou fournisseur
EDF et que nous examinons éventuellement
un renforcement des pouvoirs de la creux
sur ce sujet-là qui pourrait passer dans
un dans un texte de loi pour pouvoir
sanctionner plus rapidement le cas
échéant des fournisseurs merci beaucoup
monsieur non mais il faut poser moins de
questions et du coup c'est la parole
elle répondra peut-être à la fin parce
qu'à la fin on prend tout on prend
toutes les questions à la fin et madame
la ministre a tout le temps pour
répondre monsieur Luc Lamirault pour le
groupe horizon
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre d'abord je vous remercie pour
la présentation votre feuille de route
claire
à la fois pour le court terme et le
moyen terme
mes questions ont été suggérées par des
visites sur le terrain d'abord des
entreprises a été dit par ma collègue de
du MoDem tout à l'heure il y a une
grande inquiétude à la fois du court
terme pour les entreprises mais aussi du
moyen et long terme ils aimeraient
pouvoir savoir à quel prix on envisage
où on voudrait que l'électricité le gaz
et les différentes énergies soient
à quel niveau on souhaite que ça soit
demain je crois que c'est véritablement
un souhait fort de nos entreprises pour
pouvoir faire des plans sur le long
terme le deuxième c'est plutôt les
habitants du rural qui voit certains
port de projets sur les énergies
renouvelables arriver un peu en
conquérant et votre terme de
d'accessibilité ou d'acceptabilité
pardon de la population m'a un petit peu
rassurée simplement je vois pas comment
vous envisagez de
d'obtenir c'est accepter acceptabilité
de la population comment on peut
discuter à la fois avec les maires avec
la population quand comme je disais tout
à l'heure certains portent de porteurs
de projets arrivent en conquérant et
s'installe avec
l'habitude que finalement on leur dise
ben oui on en a besoin donc on va vous
autoriser à le faire
sur les méthaniseurs surtout nous
rencontrons cette difficulté là
sur les projets éoliens peut-être un peu
moins il y a des discussions aujourd'hui
au niveau de l'Eure-et-Loir qui font que
on a trouvé un juste milieu mais sur ces
projets de méthaniseur qui sont
nécessaire à notre pays pour pouvoir
obtenir un peu plus de gaz ou fabriquer
un peu plus de gaz j'aimerais savoir ce
que vous en pensez
madame la ministre
alors je vais pas revenir sur le sujet
de prix parce que quel est le juste prix
cela dépend aussi de combien on veut
investir derrière et quel est le mix
énergétique cible que nous nous donnons
puisqu'il est pas tout à fait positionné
de la même manière ce prix en fonction
du mix énergétique je pense qu'il faut
l'avoir en tête et c'est très clairement
l'objet de la loi
énergique climat qui a vocation vous
êtes présenté au deuxième semestre 2023
à court terme ce qui est certain c'est
qu'on a une déconnexion entre les coûts
de revient même en y ajoutant une marge
permettant aux porteur de aux
investisseurs de continuer à investir
dans des capacités de production et que
c'est cette déconnexion que nous voulons
j'ai enfin
régler avec à la fois des dispositifs
pour lutter contre la spéculation sur
les marchés et la volatilité des marchés
et de l'autre côté une contribution sur
les rentes elle fera annuelles et pour
répondre à Madame Battistel latéralement
cette contribution elle a pas vocation à
écraser ceux qui ont les coûtent
production les plus faibles elle a
vocation à répondre à ceux qui profitent
du prix entre leur coût de revient et le
coût auquel il vendent si effectivement
ils vendent à un coup serré ne sont pas
concernés par cette contribution je veux
vraiment vous rassurer sur ça et ça me
permet de répondre à votre troisième
question
s'agissant de la question des porteurs
de projets et vous indiquez plutôt le
biométhane le biogaz que le
photovoltaïque et l'éolien même si sur
le photovoltaïque on a un petit peu près
le même sujet ça va être un des objets
du projet de loi accélération des unr je
veux signaler qu'on a notamment vocation
à introduire enfin à ajouter un article
sur la grivevoltaïs puisque cela nous
est très fortement demandé par le
Conseil national de la transition
énergétique ça nous est demandé par les
agriculteurs et effectivement c'est un
élément de réglage de trouver le d'abord
la bonne définition et le bon niveau de
participation et de décision sur les
autres projets c'est un
[Musique]
2 un débat national sur le futur système
énergétique français évidemment il y a
une mission de la CNDP qui a été saisie
sur le sujet une mission de conseil et
on entend qu'il y aura un débat mais moi
j'aimerais savoir quel est le contenu de
ce débat parce qu'il n'est pas pareil il
n'est évidemment pas semblable d'avoir
un débat sur les choix énergétiques et
un choix sur quel niveau de nucléaire
jusqu'où irons-nous en la matière ce
n'est évidemment pas la même nature de
débat donc la question posée sera
essentielle de la même manière on nous
annonce une de la co-construction avec
avec notre assemblée demain seront
annoncés les prix
le nouveau bouclier tarifaire et les
prix du gaz et de l'électricité par la
première ministre il y aura une
conférence de presse où est le Parlement
dans cette dans cet exercice tout comme
on parle d'un plan de sobriété quand
est-ce que notre Parlement sera saisi
sur les questions de sobriété et c'est
sans doute un des défauts majeurs dans
la vision que non planifiée de la
transition énergétique qui est séparer
systématiquement les enjeux de sobriété
des enjeux de production on traite de
façon séparée et non de manière
rapprochée on a un calendrier législatif
pour le peu étonnant une loi sur les EnR
qui dit vouloir accélérer mais
finalement fait le silence sur un
certain nombre de d'énergie
renouvelables ouvre la voie une
déréglementation du code de
l'environnement assez assez inquiétante
ne pose pas sur la table des questions
de gouvernance c'était évoqué la place
des collectivités la place des des
citoyens dans les choix qui seront qui
seront faits et puis une loi nucléaire
qui viendrait juste derrière puis une
loi de programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie où est la cohérence quelle
vision vous portez sur cette sur cette
planification énergétique et pour
l'instant on a plutôt l'impression de
réaction à la conjoncture et d'avoir du
coup par coup et non pas cette vision
stratégique dont vous que vous évoquiez
dans votre intervention linéaire et puis
dernier point sur la question la
souveraineté énergétique moi je le dis à
la fois quand on ouvre un terminal
méthanier avec de l'importation de la
case de schiste américain on recrée de
nouvelles formes de de dépendance quand
on a de l'uranium qui arrive du Canada
du Kazakhstan ou du ou du ou du Niger on
a aussi la des vrais problèmes de
souveraineté donc comment pensez-vous
répondre à réellement à cette question
de la souveraineté énergétique madame la
ministre monsieur Fournier vous a laissé
une minute pour lui répondre
alors je vais revenir parce que j'ai
peut-être pas été clair dans mon propos
introductif donc nous avons une
politique énergétique très claire une
stratégie qui repose sur quatre leviers
la sobriété l'efficacité énergétique la
le déploiement massif des énergies
renouvelables et la relance de la
filière nucléaire sur le premier levier
c'est un plan sobriété il associe
l'ensemble du corps social et il ne fera
pas l'objet nécessairement d'une loi car
il se trouve que lorsqu'on associe par
exemple les organisations syndicales et
les partenaires et et les organisations
professionnelles elles trouvent ensemble
les voies et moyens au niveau de chaque
entreprise de faire cette sobriété et je
crois que cette concertation et ce bon
fonctionnement des institutions c'est
aussi laisser sa place au dialogue
social donc je vous réponds très
directement sur le plan sobriété nous
avons par ailleurs des textes qui ont
été votés je pense à la clim à la loi
climat résilience qui renforçait
certains éléments de sobriété et donc
nous avançons comme ça le deuxième volet
c'est l'efficacité énergétique ma prime
rénov réussir à vous connaissez ces
sujets le troisième volet c'est le
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
nous avons une loi donc tout cela est
parfaitement cohérent le quatrième volet
c'est le nucléaire nous avons également
une loi et nous vous donnons
l'opportunité d'avoir une vision globale
par un débat sur la politique
énergétique qui sera dans l'hémicycle en
entrée de cession avant l'ensemble des
textes de loi et la mise à jour de la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
elle correspond à un temps donné et à
l'effet dans les temps et la CNDP est
évidemment sur trois questions majeures
que sont la consommation énergétique
enfin le mix énergétique le mix
électrique et la stratégie de
décarbonation merci beaucoup monsieur
jumelles pour le groupe GDR
président une nouvelle fois le Parlement
est méprisé humilié la ministre ne nous
dit rien de ce que Elizabeth borne va
annoncer demain madame la ministre nul
ne peut se prévaloir de ses propres
turpitudes nous considérons dans le
domaine de l'énergie vous en avez
beaucoup libéralisation du secteur de
l'énergie siphonnage d'EDF et de ses
moyens financiers avec la reine absence
de stratégie globale stop and go le
président directeur général de DF l'a
dit pouvez-vous droit dans les yeux nous
dire que l'État n'a aucunement influencé
la politique d'EDF c'est dix dernières
années troisième sujet les particuliers
sont étranglés allez-vous mettre à
contribution ce qui les plus riches
parmi la population est un bilan en
carbone
nettement supérieur des précaires
énergétiques que connaissent le pays qui
ne peuvent pas faire face aux factures
troisième sujet les PME redoutent le
coût de massue chez moi les verriers ont
vu leur prix d'énergie multiplié par 20
et c'est maintenant que cela se pose et
c'est maintenant que les menaces de
chômage partiels se posent et c'est
maintenant que les salariés risquent de
servir de variables d'ajustement à votre
absence d'anticipation en matière de
souveraineté énergétique allez-vous
mettre en place un bouclier pour
l'économie réelle et pour nos
entreprises qui sont frappées
immédiatement troisième sujet les
collectivités locales les établissements
scolaires quatrième sujet pardon c'est
maintenant qu'elles sont à se fixées à
eux dans ma circonscription hier en
ouvrant l'enveloppe de la commission
d'appel d'offres ont passé de 350 000
euros par an pour cette petite commune à
2 millions d'euros par an au Tréport la
ville Seurre idem et donc c'est
maintenant que les piscines ferment
c'est maintenant qui est théâtres sont
fragilisés c'est maintenant que les
maires augmentent les cantines et
fragilisent toujours les mêmes à quand
quand combien de oublié pour les
collectivités qui prennent soin des
habitants un dernier mot on entend dire
que un nouveau PDG d'EDF va être nommé
lucre nom
Bercy Bercy Desmond l'Élysée entretien
le flou est-ce la signature du retour
d'Hercule et puis enfin pouvez-vous nous
dire parce que les directeurs de
centrale disent l'inverse quand ils sont
autorisés à nous parler en off que les
34 réacteurs et notamment les douze
réacteurs mis en sommeil pour cause de
corrosion ouvriront avant l'hiver dites
devant la commission vous engagez
formellement
d'abord je m'étonne que
vous vous
aimeziez que le pouvoir exécutif façon
travail le travail de la première
ministre c'est de faire des propositions
ces propositions elles sont ensuite
soumises au débat démocratique je vois
difficilement comment vous pouvez
discuter un projet de loi de finance
s'il n'y a pas une maquette de projet de
loi de finance qui vous est présentée et
donc nous sommes tous dans notre rôle le
pouvoir exécutif prépare la loi elle est
discutée ensuite au Parlement elle est
votée et nous ménageons le dialogue
social sur le terrain et le dialogue et
la concertation avec les élus rien de
nouveau sous le soleil monsieur le
député jumelles et je suis encore une
fois un peu surprise que vous ne soyez
pas plutôt en proposition sur la manière
de renforcer le bouclier énergétique ou
de saluer le fait que la France a
aujourd'hui le bouclier énergétique le
plus d'Europe est probablement du monde
et ça c'est un point qui mesure qui
mérite d'être souligné je rappelle que
fin juillet fin juin le taux d'inflation
en France était de 6% il était de 15% en
Russie il était de 9 % en Allemagne il
était de 9 % aux États-Unis il était à
deux chiffres en Inde au Brésil la
France aujourd'hui on va pas se
satisfaire d'un taux d'inflation de 6%
mais prends garde à préserver les
intérêts des ménages je me permets de
l'appuyer s'agissant de des entreprises
s'agissant des entreprises vous savez
qu'il y a 3 milliards d'euros qui ont
été réservés par Bruno Le Maire pour
accompagner les entreprises et qu'il
faut se saisir de ce dispositif et
j'appelle vraiment les entreprises à se
saisir de ce dispositif et que nous
travaillons gelés beaucoup répété au
cours de cette audition au niveau
européen à faire en sorte que les prix
reviennent à un niveau qui correspondent
plus à la réalité physique du prix de
l'électricité je rappelle qu'en 10 jours
le l'électricité passer de 1000 euros à
600 euros et donc j'invite vraiment les
comment dire les collectivités locales
aussi à être vigilantes sur les
propositions qui sont faites par les
fournisseurs je donne la parole à
Nathalie à Nathalie bassire du groupe
je vous remercie
la ministre cela a été dit la crise
énergétique à laquelle nous faisons face
nous met face à une perspective
inquiétante le rationnement subi de
notre consommation nous n'aurait pu en
effet prévoir la guerre en Ukraine et la
raie des livraisons russes de gaz en
revanche nous aurions pu en minimiser
l'impact en accroissant notre
souveraineté énergétique qui ne se
décrète pas en quelques jours et en
orientant également notre société vers
davantage de sobriété énergétiques en la
matière les insuffisances françaises
sont pates le Haut Conseil pour le
climat là d'ailleurs rappelé dans son
dernier rapport aujourd'hui nous en
sommes réduits à gérer l'urgence et
plusieurs questions se posent sur les
moyens d'accompagner nos citoyens nos
concitoyens face à la hausse des prix et
de renforcer la résilience de notre
système énergétique et concernant vous
aviez parlé de du bouclier tarifaire
Bruno Le Maire a annoncé de nouveaux
contours pour le bouclier tarifaire en
2023 quelle est la hausse à prévoir pour
le prix du gaz et de l'électricité le
échec énergie sera-t-il énergie élargi
pardon un nouveau public et une
revalorisation de son montant est-elle
étudiée les entreprises pour leur part
ne devraient pas bénéficier normalement
du bouclier tarifaire les
électro-intensives devraient tout de
même bénéficier d'une subvention ciblée
visant à compenser les surcoûts de
dépenses de gaz ou d'électricité jusque
là la complexité de l'aide la rendez peu
accessible vous avez décidé d'en
simplifier les critères les dispositifs
rencontrent-ils enfin du succès et puis
d'autre part le projet de loi relatif à
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables nous considérons que les
mesures transitoires loin de simplifier
le processus risque d'accroître le
nombre de contentieux en dématérialisant
le processus de consultation citoyenne
et en démarrant l'enquête publique sans
l'avis de l'autorité environnementale ne
pensez-vous pas que le risque est de
dégrader encore un peu plus l'accessible
l'acceptabilité sociale des énergies
renouvelables et allez également en
parallèle de ce projet de loi renforcer
les moyens des dréals et de l'autorité
environnementale pour accélérer le
traitement des dossiers je vous remercie
madame la ministre
ok alors ça va me permettre de revenir
sur la question du niveau des prix pour
les entreprises je vais pas revenir sur
le bouclier tarifaire vous avez compris
que le gouvernement s'est engagé à
amortir le l'augmentation du prix de
l'énergie chaque année vous avez une
proposition de la creux qui propose une
augmentation des prix et chaque année
nous acceptons ou nous prenons la
décision d'amortir l'augmentation des
prix et cette décision là elle a
clairement été communiquée les
paramètres vous seront communiqués
prochainement s'agissant du chèque
énergie je peux vous confirmer que tout
travaillons effectivement sur un
renforcement de ce chèque énergie mais
là encore les paramètres vous seront
soumis prochainement s'agissant des
entreprises je veux rappeler que c'est
le relèvement de volume d'arène l'année
dernière qui a permis de faire un
bouclier très important en matière de
prix l'électricité pour les entreprises
que ce relèvement de la reine et la
contribu éviter les faillites
d'entreprises intensives je dis
notamment pour Monsieur le Député
jumelles qui est très attaché à la
vallée de la Bresle et qui sont des
entreprises qui utilisent beaucoup
d'électricité pour les fours variés et
les entreprises hyper électro-intensifs
et qui ont permis de contenir un peu
près en réduisant de 50% la facture
d'électricité donc ça va effectivement
être une fonction du volume d'arène ça
va être une fonction aussi du travail
que nous faisons de déconnexion des prix
de l'électricité du gaz et de la remise
je dirais au bon niveau du marché de
l'électricité et puis nous disposons de
leviers avec le cadre de soutien
ukrainien ce cadre de soutien qui qui
permet d'avoir 3 milliards d'euros
d'accompagnement pour les entreprises et
en particulier celle qui ont plus de 3%
de leurs dépenses consacrée à l'énergie
en temps normal merci
problème la ministre donc nous avons
terminé avec les orateurs de groupe nous
allons donc passer aux intervenants
individuels j'ai 20 demandes de prise de
parole monsieur Bothorel monsieur
Martinet Cordier madame Babou monsieur
potier mais madame bourra madame Lemeur
madame Simonet monsieur Vigier fais la
liste
monsieur gaillard
monsieur Rolland monsieur Végéta
monsieur Girardin madame Blin madame
Petel monsieur Marchive monsieur Perrot
monsieur travers monsieur Paco et
Monsieur Royer Perrot est-ce que j'ai
oublié alors c'est Madame Simonet je
crois que vous étiez dedans oui si vous
êtes dedans
ok on va noter les prises de par
additionnel tout le monde va pouvoir le
faire par contre vous avez vu là je vais
redonner la règle comme ça on est clair
parce qu'il faut voilà c'est une minute
max je coupe vraiment la minute vous
avez le chrono qui est juste ici vous
voilà je vous laisse vous gérez mais à
une minute vous comprendrez bien que
vous le nom d'intervenants je suis
obligé de couper et elle a toute femme
elle aime la ministre vous répondrai à
la totalité de ces questions on est
d'accord on y va on commence Monsieur
Eric bottoel c'est à vous
alors que la France est largement
amputée de sa capacité de production
nucléaire et que l'approvisionnement en
gaz est incertain cet hiver RTE le
gestionnaire du réseau de transport
d'électricité continue d'alerter sur un
risque de pénurie d'électricité depuis
fin août le gouvernement invite les
entreprises françaises à diminuer 10 %
leur consommation d'énergie afin
d'éviter la pénurie redoutée par les
professionnels du secteur pouvant mener
jusqu'au blackout c'est en ce sens que
les groupes de travail sectoriels ont
été créés par les ministres concernés
afin déterminer les pistes de sobriété
énergétique des entreprises françaises
si les mesures de sobriété ne sont pas
suffisantes des ordres de délestage
pourrait être émis par enedis afin
d'éviter le redouter blackout ces
coupures seraient réalisées de manière
quasi indifférenciée et susceptible de
concerner de nombreux installations
industrielles y compris les
installations de communication
électronique portant indispensables
notamment pour l'acheminement des
communications d'urgence vers le SAMU
les pompiers ou encore la gendarmerie de
police c'est pourquoi je voudrais savoir
si le gouvernement allait exigé des
Medis de préserver l'alimentation en
électricité des infrastructures de
communication mobile et de les classer
ainsi en installation non délestable au
sens de l'arrêté du 5 juillet 1990
monsieur maisonnet
madame la ministre nous sommes je crois
tous ici attentifs à vos différentes
déclarations médiatiques qui sont
souvent d'ailleurs la garantie de
moments déconcertants je dirais et je
voulais évoquer ici avec vous les propos
que vous avez tenus ce dimanche au sujet
des voitures électriques vous avez
évoqué dans cette interview la
possibilité que les utilisateurs de
voiture électrique pourraient demain
réinjecter de l'électricité dans le
réseau depuis les batteries de leur
véhicule alors je vous avoue que cela
m'a un petit peu là encore interpellé je
serai assez curieux d'avoir un peu plus
de détails sur ce que vous entendez par
là c'est à dire madame la ministre que
les propriétaires de ce type de véhicule
se verront signifier la réquisition de
leur véhicule et de leur électricité
stockée dans leur voiture en pratique ça
va faire fonctionner comment il
recevront SMS de RTE il devront se
présenter à la borne pour décharger leur
véhicule est-ce que les bornes
installées un peu partout en France sont
prévus pour cela est-ce que cette
électricité sera rachetée réquisition
volontari je vous remercie de m'apporter
un éclairage merci beaucoup monsieur
martinet
madame la ministre j'étais vendredi sur
ma circonscription plus précisément dans
la ville de la verrière et j'ai discuté
avec des locataires HLM qui était dans
une situation de détresse absolue pour
une raison très simple c'est qu'il
venait de recevoir un courrier de leur
bailleur social je vais me permettre de
vous en lire un extrait nous avons
demandé les aides de l'État relative au
bouclier tarifaire néanmoins cette
mesure ne permet pas de couvrir la
totalité de l'augmentation des prix du
gaz le montant de vos provisions de
charge de chauffage facturé
mensuellement sur vos avis d'échéance
vont donc être revus à la hausse ce
montant passera de
62,56 euros à
199,7 euros je le répète
62,56 euros à 199,7 euros madame la
ministre les locataires HLM de la ville
de La Verrière ce sont les travailleurs
essentiels aide-soignante agent de
sécurité caissière livreur ils ne
peuvent pas supporter cette augmentation
de leur charge malheureusement votre
bouclier tarifaire en réalité est un
bouclier en carton il ne protège pas des
locataires de cette augmentation de
charge et le plus scandale monsieur
Cordier merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre je voudrais vous
parler des citoyens qui se chauffent au
bois et notamment des personnes qui ont
investi ces dernières années avec un
certain nombre de dispositifs de l'État
d'ailleurs sur des poils à pellets et il
s'avère qu'actuellement le pellet
explose en terme de prix en l'occurrence
X2 ou x 3 dans mon département des
Ardennes c'est le cas et je reçois
beaucoup de citoyens dans mes
permanences comme nombre d'entre vous
j'imagine qui qui évoque ce sujet je
voulais savoir si vous avez des pistes
très concrètes envisagées parce qu'il y
a aucune raison et la guerre en Ukraine
n'explique absolument rien ni les
tensions sur les énergies fossiles il
s'agit ici du bois donc voilà beaucoup
de citoyens attendent des réponses
concrètes sur le sujet de l'augmentation
du prix du pellet je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur Cordier madame Babou
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre la sobriété est un outil
essentielle à la décarbonation de notre
société vous l'avez d'ailleurs rappelé
récemment la meilleure énergie est celle
que l'on ne consomme pas la sobriété que
nous devons défendre est à mon sens à
politique du moins mais mieux vous
l'avez dit elle est un outil à plus long
terme pour que notre pays soit au
rendez-vous de la transition écologique
j'aimerais donc savoir quelle méthode
comptez-vous engagée avec l'ensemble des
acteurs mais également avec les Français
sur leur consommation énergétique et
comment assurer que cette sobriété ne se
perde une fois les prix de l'énergie
seront revenus à la normale au delà nous
allons prochainement discuter de
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables sur ce point il me semble
que la question des super profits
représente une opportunité pour
accélérer le développement des EnR en
adoptant une logique de planification
publique privée ainsi l'État pourrait
fixer des objectifs d'investissement
producteur d'énergie pour qu'ils
utilisent une part de ses profits afin
d'amplifier le développement des EnR on
peut imaginer une logique similaire pour
les autres entreprises avec des
programmes de décarbonation de leur
activité comme la récemment annoncé
c'est macgm cela serait à mon sens plus
pertinent qu'une taxation en FA
merci beaucoup monsieur potier merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
avant de répondre à mes propres
questions pouvez-vous répondre à celle
de ma collègue marinel Battistel sur les
tarifs réglementés comment
amortissez-vous le coût du bouclier et
allez vous les prolonger en conséquence
et quelle mesure prenez-vous contre la
fraude à la reine et que certains
revendent sur les marchés énergétiques
au détriment d'EDF donc des questions
qui ont été posées vous aura
l'opportunité d'y répondre à nouveau les
questions qui étaient les miennes
étaient peut-être de ne pas tourner en
dérision la planification écologique qui
a été évoquée par un mouvement politique
chez nous et repris par le Président de
la République vous avez parlé d'usine à
gaz moi je suis persuadé que la
planification écologique bien pensée
c'est au contraire un accélérateur et
c'est partager le sol c'est partager la
valeur savoir un modèle d'économie
sociale et territoriale pour le
développement des EnR notre groupe se
rapporteur de propositions très précises
qui ne ralentissent pas mais qui
accélère et garantissent dans la durée
une bonne orientation de ces enr et pas
seulement ceux qui sont prévus dans la
loi êtes-vous ouverte à ses propositions
merci beaucoup monsieur petit monsieur
Benoît
si monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre comme j'ai confiance en vous
comme vous êtes une mini qui travaillait
je vais vous poser une question assez
simple en matière d'énergie madame la
ministre
ce qu'on explique aujourd'hui aux
Français au chef d'entreprise aux
industriels enfin à tous ceux qui ont
besoin d'énergie c'est exactement le
contraire de ce qu'on raconte depuis 10
ans
et je voudrais madame la ministre vous
interpellez pour savoir comment vous
allez retisser les liens de confiance
avec les industriels avec les
collectivités locales avec les Français
lorsque pendant 10 ans 5 ans on a
entendu Monsieur Hulot monsieur Campin
monsieur de Rugy madame Pompili nous
racontait exactement le contraire de ce
qu'elle raconte le président de la
République aujourd'hui merci
très bien merci Monsieur Benoît monsieur
Bourgoin
pardon excusez-moi madame excusez-moi
toutes mes excuses je suis vraiment
désolé excusez-moi
merci madame la ministre le gouvernement
a annoncé de la prolongation du bouclier
tarifaire sur l'énergie en 2023 ce
dispositif ne permettra pas toutefois
d'absorber la hausse à venir et le
ministre de l'Économie a déjà prévenu
que la facture au final augmente aura
pour tout le monde aujourd'hui près de
12 millions de nos concitoyens sont déjà
en situation de précarité énergétique
voici ma question envisagez-vous
d'augmenter de manière significative le
montant du chèque énergie et d'élargir
sa distribution afin d'éviter au ménages
les plus modestes de s'imposer des
restrictions de consommation en ne
chauffant que certaines pièces ou en
maintenant un niveau de température
inférieure au seuil de confort ou encore
plus inquiétant d'utiliser d'autres
méthodes de choses de chauffe pardon au
détriment de leur sécurité je pense en
particulier à ceux qui habitent les
passoires thermiques pour lesquelles
vous n'avez pas engagé les moyens
nécessaires cette dernière année pour
assurer la rénovation des logements je
vous remercie merci Madame Lemeur s'il
vous plaît merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre votre prédécesseur
avait commandé à EDF en décembre 2021 un
audit sur la performance des arrêts de
réacteurs nucléaires pour rappel cette
demande avait été formulée suite à
l'annonce de RTE que la sécurité
d'approvisionnement pour l'hiver dernier
rester sous vigilance particulière dans
le contexte ou la disponibilité du parc
nucléaire commençait à diminuer du fait
du problème de corrosion sous contrainte
aujourd'hui ce sont une trentaine de
réacteurs qui sont à l'arrêt en raison
de maintenance ou et de corrosion sous
contrainte cette audit sur la
disponibilité du parc nucléaire français
a-t-il bien été mené par EDF et si oui
ne soyons pas pudique levons le voile
quelles sont ses conclusions
merci beaucoup madame le Maire madame
Simonet c'est à vous
bien je doute de la pertinence de cette
session de questions puisque de toute
façon tout a été décidé en comité
défense et que de fait c'est de maths
nous apprendrons par la conférence de
presse qui les d'ores et déjà décidé
d'augmenter les factures et tarifs du
gaz électrique cité et qu'il y aura un
plan de sobriété néanmoins je pense que
ma question les collectivités madame la
ministre ne sont pas concernés par le
bouclier tarifaire puisqu'elles ont été
contraintes d'abandonner les tarifs
réglementés de vente en 2020 hormis les
toutes petites collectivités qui
embauchent moins de 10% de 10 personnes
la majorité d'entre elles font donc face
à des hausses de factures d'énergie sans
précédent il y a l'arrivée ça veut dire
quoi soit on ferme certains services
publics soit ça veut dire que les
collectivités vont être obligés
d'exploser leurs tarifs alors j'ai donc
la question que comptez-vous faire pour
aider les collectivités dans cette
situation ils le font vers annoncer par
la ministre madame borne pour aider les
collectivités sur la transition
énergétique n'est que de 1 milliard et
demi alors pourquoi s'obstiner à refuser
une taxe monsieur Vigier
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre dans le cadre du plan de
sobriété énergétique et vous l'avez
précisé vous avez fixé l'objectif de
réduire de 10% la consommation d'énergie
d'ici deux ans les collectivités
territoriales sont ainsi appelés à jouer
un rôle crucial dans la poursuite de cet
objectif mais j'aimerais souligner tout
particulièrement le fait que nos
collectivités locales et nos communes
rurales sont déjà souvent exemplaires en
la matière avec un des investissements
et deux des bonnes pratiques qui ont
contribué à réduire fortement leur
consommation d'énergie mais dans
certains cas ça ne suffit pas aussi
pouvez-vous nous préciser quelle sera
l'action ou la compagnement du
gouvernement pour être aux côtés de nos
collectivités locales notamment nos
communes rurales dans ce domaine qui
doivent être soutenus et non pas
pénalisés je vous remercie merci
Monsieur gaillard
madame la ministre l'ambition de la
souveraineté énergétique de la France et
des Outre-mer est un objectif que nous
partageons pleinement néanmoins cette
ambition ne résiste pas au fait en effet
le fond de pension américain KKR
viendrater 90% du capital d'albioma
albiomag groupe créé en 1982 est issu de
la CEDEC et de la Séchilienne
aujourd'hui albioma s'affiche comme le
premier fournisseur d'électricité à la
Réunion en produisant 46% de l'énergie
disponible sur le réseau grâce à
l'exploitation notamment de deux
centrales thermiques en biomasse en
avril dernier albioma engage une
procédure d'OPA amicale avec le fond
d'investissement américain KKR qui a
racheté l'entreprise à 50 euros l'action
soit 1,5 fois son prix à début mars
cette opération était approuvée par
l'Autorité des marchés financiers
fait une acceptable à nos yeux BPI
France a baissé sa participation dans
albioma le 1er août dernier par
l'intermédiaire de la Société BPI France
investissement SAS qui part de 5% à 3,59
pour cent du capital tous ces éléments
démontrent parfaitement que l'objectif
de souveraineté énergétique de la France
n'est qu'un gros mensonge non seulement
la France et en l'occurrence notre île
la réunion ne seront plus à même de
diriger le développement du secteur de
l'énergie biomasse mais en outre il est
de notoriété publique que calcaire
effectue ce qu'on appelle Monsieur
Roland
madame la ministre deux ou trois
questions très binaires la première est
vous n'y avez pas encore répondu OUI ou
NON l'ensemble des réacteurs nucléaires
fonctionneront-ils pour l'hiver deuxième
question l'État est-il prêt à
accompagner un projet d'arrivée de gaz
naturel dans la valet de tarentèse qui
viendrait soulager les industriels dans
leurs besoins et réduire de manière
significative les gaz à effet de serre
et troisième question dernière
prévoyez-vous pour les entreprises
saisonnières des dispositifs d'aide pour
qu'elles puissent amortir entre
guillemets l'augmentation du coût de
l'énergie
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur Vegeta
alors la construction du mic 4 avait été
invalidée sur la base d'une étude d'une
étude analyse coup bénéfice réalisée en
2017 qui estimait alors des coûts de
construction supérieure à la valeur
apportée par la nouvelle infrastructure
nous voisins et partenaires espagnols et
portugais animés dans ce sens par le
gouvernement allemand choisi de remettre
le mid4 au centre du débat sur les
interconnexions énergétiques entre la
France et la péninsule ibérique le mid4
ne sera pas une réponse à la crise
actuelle nous le savons mais force est
de reconnaître que les perspectives à
plus long terme du marché énergétique
européen et les manifestations du
réchauffement climatique ont évolué
drastiquement depuis 2017 la perception
de la situation par nos amis ibérique a
évolué notamment du fait des politiques
des promotions de l'hydrogène vert au
sud des Pyrénées ainsi que des capacités
excellentaires de l'Espagne en
regazification du GNL ma question est
donc pourquoi ne pas réaliser une
analyse actualisée des impacts ou
bénéfices de cette infrastructure sur la
base de ces nouveaux scénarios afin de
pouvoir amener nos part faire mieux
comprendre voire même de nous soutenir
de notre décision merci Monsieur Vegeta
monsieur l'aîné
merci président madame la ministre vous
avez indiqué compter sur EDF pour tenir
le rythme de redémarrage des réacteurs
dans les prochaines semaines et les
prochains mois or depuis cet été plus de
la moitié du parc nucléaire est à
l'arrêt du fait de problème de corrosion
sous contrainte de retard de maintenance
mais aussi des conséquences du
changement climatique première question
pensez-vous alors que les conditions de
sûreté sont aujourd'hui suffisantes pour
cette reprise pensez-vous que le risque
de corrosion puisse être écarté alors
même qu'il s'agit d'un phénomène
pernicieux détectable seulement après
une longue période d'incubation
existe-t-il des solutions industrielles
pour éviter à l'avenir c'est
défaillances à quel prix et à quel
inchéance deuxième question au regard de
ces problèmes de sûreté et en
considérant que le Pr de Flamanville a
déjà coûté près de 20 milliards et n'est
toujours pas en marche est-il
raisonnable de prévoir la construction
de nouveau EPR troisième et dernière
question enfin comment parler de
souveraineté énergétique de la France
alors que l’uranium est principalement
importé du Niger et du Kazakhstan il
semblerait par ailleurs que des f se
soient fait livrer récemment 52 fûts
d'uranium enrichis de Russie quelle
cohérence de la politique internationale
menée par la France merci beaucoup
monsieur Gérardin
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre merci déjà pour votre
présentation le président de la
République a annoncé son souhait de voir
diminuer les dépenses énergétiques
françaises de 10% à d'ici 2024 dans ce
cadre est déjà depuis 5 ans nous avons
fortement investi dans la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments grâce à des
dispositifs comme ma prime rénoeuvre et
le plan de rénovation de 700 000
logements programmés par an s'inscrit en
dynamique du mandat précédent la
rénovation énergétique c'est de
l'activité de l'emploi du pouvoir
d'achat rendu aux Français et bien sûr
la protection de notre planète mais les
professionnels du secteur m'ont indiqué
qu'il n'avait que peu de visibilité sur
les aides accordées dont les conditions
d'obtention ont beaucoup changé
notamment en 2021 ils disent ne pas
savoir lesquels sont encore valables ni
pour combien de temps aussi je
souhaiterais vous interroger pour savoir
s'il était envisagé de créer un
dispositif clair pérenne est plus
puissant permettant d'une part d'un
informant les professionnels
particulier sur les aides afin d'inciter
à la réalisation bénéfique pour
l'économie merci beaucoup la parole est
à Monsieur de fonda
au micro madame la ministre le
gouvernement anticipé le départ du PDG
de DF monsieur Levi 6 mois avant la fin
de son mandat décision plus que
surprenante qui consiste à congédier le
patron de DF en pleine crise énergétique
mais surtout ne comprend pas pourquoi le
faire maintenant si Monsieur levier
était mauvais alors pourquoi n'a-t-il
pas été remplacé plus tôt et s'il était
bon là pourquoi ne pas les garder
jusqu'au bout pourriez-vous nous dire
les véritables raisons qui ont conduit
le gouvernement à remplacer monsieur
leviat dans la fin de son mandat
êtes-vous pas en réalité à la recherche
d'un patron d'EDF qui soit capable de
s'adapter au changement régulier de
stratégie
très bien merci beaucoup madame blanc
c'est à vous
merci monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre je voudrais vous interroger sur
des mesures que vous envisagez pour les
particuliers les entreprises de manière
à ce que les Français sachent
véritablement ce à quoi ils doivent
s'attendre vous avez évoqué dans vos
propos liminaires la mise en place de
contrats en fonction de la sobriété des
utilisateurs est-ce que c'est un premier
pas vers un passé énergétique tel qu'il
avait été évoqué dans la presse au début
de cet été ensuite nous avons
entendu que vous envisagiez et comme ça
a été dit par plusieurs collègues des
mesures de délestage pour les
entreprises comment seront-elles
sélectionnées quelles seront les mesures
qui seront mises en place très
concrètement pour elle vous parliez
aussi de sobriété qui est notamment
devait prendre toute sa force dans le
dialogue social mais le CNR mis en place
par le Président de la République
notamment évoque cette question
énergétique quel sera l'articulation
avec la fameuse consultation dont vous
nous avez également parlé en propos
liminaire et si vous pouviez également
madame Petel c'est à vous merci monsieur
le Président Madame la Ministre moi je
souhaite vous interroger sur les aides
au soutien à l'autonomie énergétique et
l'autosuffisance des habitations et des
locaux professionnels vous avez engagé
un grand plan de sobriété et nous y
souscrivons pleinement mais nous avons
aussi dans nos territoires et
particulièrement dans les territoires
ruraux des exemples de particuliers de
coopérative engagés dans
l'autosuffisance ou l'autonomie
énergétique ça peut être d'un quartier
d'une maison d'un bâtiment si les grands
investissements d'infrastructures pour
la production d'énergie sont nécessaires
et vous en avez parlé il ne faut pas
négliger le développement et
l'incitation à l'autonomie énergétique
et à l'autosuffisance à la fois pour des
raisons de pouvoir d'achat mais aussi
pour faciliter l'implication des
citoyens dans la transition énergétique
aussi je souhaiterais savoir si le
Gouvernement entend suivre cette voie et
amplifier les aides aux installations
individuelles de production d'énergie
simplifier les démarches administratives
et intégrer cette composante dans la
stratégie énergétique de notre pays
merci beaucoup monsieur mar
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre le 5 septembre dernier le
président de la République annonçait
vouloir aller beaucoup plus vite sur le
sujet de la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments le contexte énergétique actuel
nous dit encourage évidemment et plus
particulièrement dans les centres
historiques il apparaît en effet que les
bâtiments anciens sont actuellement
soumis à des contraintes difficilement
conciliables avec ses impératifs
énergétiques à l'heure où la location de
logement classée FG devient a juste
titre interdite l'installation
d'équipements tels que les panneaux
solaires ou pompe à chaleur se trouvent
de fait paradoxalement impossible ces
motifs patrimoniaux sont évidemment
compréhensibles et justifiées pour
autant face aux enjeux climatiques il y
a là un vivier non négligeable
d'économie d'énergie alors des
dispositifs comme ma prime rénov le font
friche ou l'opail contribue déjà mais le
défi reste immense je pense
particulièrement aux avis conformes des
architectes des bâtiments de France que
les travaux réalisés sur ces biens
doivent nécessairement respecter et qui
à ce jour on intègre qu'une approche
légale exclusivement patrimoniale et non
énergétique
je me permets donc madame la ministre de
vous interroger sur les réflexions en
cours qui nous permettent de mieux
concilier préservation monsieur mial et
son VTT monsieur perron
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre dans le cadre de notre
transition énergétique plusieurs projets
conduits dans le cadre d'une démarche
cercle vertueuse inquiète malgré tout
certains acteurs dont ceux de la filière
bois en effet les séries les industriels
de cette filière doivent avoir
absolument accès à la matière première
une diminution des activités affecterait
directement les volumes de sures
nécessaires notamment à la production de
pellets le sécurité est abordé tout à
l'heure par notre collègue galère et là
en ce moment cette ressource même et
sous tension par un manque alors que
dans les territoires ruraux en
particulier ça s'inscrit directement
dans la stratégie que l'on a porté sous
la mandature précédente et notamment le
changement des chaudières fuel et enfin
la hausse du nombre de projets utilisant
la biomasse risque déstabiliser les
filières de valorisation des déchets du
bois qui serai un manque à gagner pour
nous tous madame la ministre comme un
côté vous prendre en considération ces
problématiques au cœur de la stratégie
gouvernementale que vous portez merci
super merci beaucoup monsieur Paco
madame la ministre favorisée par ma
prime rénov à l'interdiction de
l'installation des chaudières au fioul
et les ventes de chauffage au granulés
ont connu une croissance fulgurante plus
41% entre 2021 et 2021 pour les poils à
granulés plus 120 % pour les chaudières
conséquence ça demande au granulés de
bois ou de granulés de bois ou pellets
n'a jamais été aussi forte et bien que
ce combustible soit local avec une
production française à 85% les tarifs
ont explosés alors maintenant le prix
d'une palette d'une tonne conditionnée
en sac de 15 kg et passer d'environ 300
euros après de 800 euros de ce fait les
consommateurs ont tendance à stocker
créant des pénuries dans certaines
régions aussi madame la ministre quelle
mesure le gouvernement qu'on te met en
oeuvre pour faire face à cette situation
inédite un bouclier tarifaire est-il
envisageable pour soutenir nos
concitoyens qui ont fait l'effort de
s'équiper d'un mode de chauffage en
énergie renouvelable et pouvez-vous nous
garantir qu'il n'y aura pas de pénurie
de ce combustible cet hiver merci merci
beaucoup
oui monsieur monsieur le président
madame la ministre vous avez rappelé
fort à propos donc le bouclier
énergétique mis en place par le
gouvernement que ce soit pour les
particuliers ou pour que pour les
entreprises je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur la situation de ceux qui
sont en cours de créer leur entreprise
et pour lesquelles la facture
énergétique peut être finalement un
frein je prends un exemple dans ma
circonscription un chef d'entreprise à
deux Intermarchés un Intermarché qui
existe facture énergétique 60 000 euros
par an il est en train de créer un
deuxième Intermarché facture énergétique
estimé 400 000 euros évidemment les 400
000 euros c'est un équilibre économique
qu'il ne peut pas supporter et donc je
pense que si on extrapole ce
raisonnement cela peut avoir comme
incidence que les personnes qui sont en
train de créer des entreprises et bien
refusent enfin se mettre en situation de
danger et donc cale dans leur projet
entrepreneurial et donc quel est les
actions quelles sont les actions que le
gouvernement pourraient prendre pour
répondre merci beaucoup madame en grand
Madame le Ministre chers collègues une
question courte directe mais
opérationnelle jeudi dernier la cristal
d'Arc annonçait la mise en chômage
partiel de 1600 personnes la fermeture
du four d le four le plus performant 350
personnes directement concernées cette
entreprise déjà en grande difficulté
depuis quelques années aujourd'hui est
en grand danger quels sont vos
propositions sur le plan énergétique
pour sauvegarder les emplois des 10000
personnes concernées sur le bassin de
Saint-Omer merci Madame lemy merci et
nous allons terminer cette très longue
série de questions avec Madame trouvez
c'est à vous
madame la ministre Richard collègue j'ai
posé la question la plus courte de cette
séance mais qui a déjà été posée par mon
collègue Mathias Tavel mais qui est
restée sans réponse à savoir au vu des
profondes défaillances du marché
européen de l'électricité comptez-vous
en sortir madame la ministre voilà
[Musique]
alors je veux frustrer personne donc
Madame la porte allez-y merci monsieur
le président
qui est dans ma circonscription dans mon
département du Lot-et-Garonne va
s'implanter le plus grand parc
photovoltaïque d'Europe il va y avoir
800 hectares de maïs qui vont être
transformés en panneau photovoltaïque
les propriétaires vont louer leur terre
plus de 4000 euros l'hectare à l'année
vous doutez bien que la production maïs
est bien moins lucrative au même titre
que la production des biocarburants qui
supprime des terres arables comment
anticipez-vous le fait que de nombreux
propriétaires vont renoncer à utiliser
leur terre pour des productions
agricoles au même titre que les
propriétaires forestiers devant de tels
montants à la clé je vous remercie
et donc on termine avec monsieur
Martineau
merci monsieur le président
le signalez-vous quand même avant parce
que là on en finit plus enfin je
bon monsieur Martino allez-y et puis en
avance merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre une petite question
prévoyez-vous des aides ou des mesures
exceptionnelles pour les agriculteurs
car justement il y a aussi des problèmes
de stockage et je connais certains
agriculteurs qui justement préfèrent ne
pas récolter car il n'arriveront pas à
répercuter le coût de stockage exemple
dans les fruits et légumes ou même sur
les serres en ce qui concerne par
exemple les tomates madame Goulet
dernière question on arrête là
rappeler l'Assemblée nationale travaille
c'est pas parce qu'il y a pas une
session extraordinaire bah les
commissions sont au travail les
ministres viennent rendre des comptes
devant la représentation nationale et
c'est ça aussi la démocratie alors
madame la ministre vous avez toutes ces
questions vous allez essayer cette
exploit de répondre à tout le monde je
sais pas si vous allez y arriver en une
quinzaine de minutes parce que là on a
déjà pris beaucoup de retard par rapport
à nos futurs auditions et on a déjà
décalé l'audition suivante de du
ministre Klein et donc en une quinzaine
de minutes si vous pouvez ramasser vos
réponses pour répondre à la
représentation nationale ce serait
absolument superbe en tout cas bon
courage madame la ministre
alors Monsieur Bothorel sur la question
du Daily stage donc je rappelle que 1 il
n'y a pas de risque de blackout le
blackout c'est la survenue d'un épisode
qui fait effondrer l'ensemble du système
énergétique c'est pour ça qu'il y a un
plan de continuité qui est préparé et
qui est l'ultime recours avec en cas de
d'insuffisance d'alimentation en
électricité et que c'est vous avez un
certain nombre de mesures notamment les
délaissages qui pourraient être activés
en cas d'ultime difficulté et que les
délaissages s'est organisé les gens sont
prévenus ça ne concerne qu'un moins de
5% des compteurs donc c'est juste pour
remettre les choses en perspective
s'agissant de qui enfin de du rôle et de
qui est essentiel c'est un travail qui
est actuellement mené avec la filière
infrastructure numérique qui nous ont
alerté sur le problème de leurs antennes
et nous avons effectivement pris en
compte le rôle qu'il joue dans les
dispositifs de sécurité et le notamment
d'être le lien pour les populations avec
l'extérieur mais en tout état de cause
nous devons aussi faire en sorte que
compte tenu du réseau d'antenne qui est
situé sur le territoire soit on repère
des antennes non délestables soit
effectivement on passe par d'autres
moyens donc le point est bien regardé un
plan de continuité sur les voitures
électriques
la question sur lequel j'ai répondu
auquel vous mentionnez c'est
effectivement est-ce que il y a lieu de
développer la marche forcée des voitures
électriques dès lors qu'on peut avoir un
souci d'alimentation en électricité
c'est une question de moyens long terme
je me permets de le rappeler et donc il
n'est pas question de réquisition de
quoi que vous ayez mentionné en revanche
je peux d'ores et déjà vous dire que
vous avez des opérateurs de recharge de
voiture électrique qui ont des contrats
d'effacement ou de mise à disposition
d'électricité parce qu'il coupe la
charge avec du stockage et qu'ils sont
capables d'en renvoyer des gigawatts sur
le réseau donc ce sont effectivement des
dispositifs qui existent et qu'à partir
du moment où vous avez quelque part une
batterie vous avez la capacité à créer
de la résilience sur les réseaux et je
suis à votre disposition pour
approfondir ce point je pense que la
pédagogie est toujours utile en matière
politique niveau des charges dans les
offices publics d'alchimède c'est un
point sur lequel
Olivier Klein que vous auditionnez après
est évidemment extraordinairement
mobilisé vous avez raison de souligner
ce sujet d'augmentation de décharge et
il je pense qu'il vous répondra mieux
que moi sur la question des pellets vous
êtes plusieurs à avoir signalé ce point
d'abord pour vous rappeler que la le
pellet est un sous-produit de
l'industrie du bois et que l'industrie
du bois est sensible au coût du gaz et
l'électricité puisqu'il y a des
procédures électriques et de chauffe
que de ce fait sans compter les
problèmes de transport etc et les coûts
inhérents vous avez effectivement une
augmentation très sensible des prix que
nous observons que nous avons pris des
mesures pour faciliter la production de
pellets ne pas être en situation
d'impasse d'approvisionnement que sur
les prix la mesure qui est la plus à
même de répondre à votre question c'est
le chèque énergie puisqu'il permet de
couvrir le prix des pellets ce qui
suppose effectivement d'avoir une
réflexion sur une possible augmentation
de ce chèque énergie et que c'est à
mettre en regard du chèque enfin de la
mesure fuel puisque vous avez raison de
souligner qu'il serait
plutôt curieux que les chaudières à
fioules soient à aider avec une
augmentation réelle du prix du fioul
mais pas les systèmes qui fonctionnent
avec des pellets que nous sommes bien
conscients de sujets là et que j'ai
alerté la première ministre et ministre
de l'économie pour qu'on ait bien un
alignement et pour que les personnes qui
se chauffent au pellet puissent avoir je
dirais de manière équitable
également un soutien qui passerait à
priori par le chèque par le chèque
énergie mais voilà je suis à votre
disposition pour en discuter on a bien
viré matérialiser le point sur la
sobriété comment s'assurer que c'est
durable cela va être cranté dans les
trajectoires nationales bas carbone et
vous savez que ces trajectoires sont
vont devenir mordante au fil du temps
c'est à dire qu'à un moment ça sera un
coût pour les acteurs économiques donc
pourquoi mettre en place un plan
sobriété parce que vous avez des
convictions sur le réchauffement
climatique premièrement deuxième élément
parce que vous baissez votre facture
énergétique troisième élément parce que
des stratégies et toute la politique que
nous menons notamment dans le cadre du
paquet climat européen vont conduire à
payer pour les acteurs économiques je
parle pas des ménages mais pour les
acteurs économiques un coût progressif
de la tonne carbone et donc c'est une
incitation à éviter
d'émettre du CO2 sur la question
des tarifs réglementés madame baptistel
et qui avait été repris par Monsieur
potier nous n'avons pas besoin d'un
tarif réglementé je dirais techniquement
nous n'avons pas besoin d'un tarif
réglementé pour mettre en place un
bouclier donc vous savez que le tervégaz
a fait l'objet d'une décision de justice
européenne et qu'elle contraire à
l'Europe mais ça nous empêche pas de
définir un système de bouclier le cas
échéant sur le gaz
sur la question de la fraude à la reine
j'avais déjà répondu monsieur le député
potier pour le redire euh nous avons
ouvert enfin j'ai demandé à la
présidente de la creux de
systématiquement ouvrir des enquêtes en
cas de doute et je rappelle que le
supplément d'arène qui vous le
trop-plein d'arène dont sous certains
fournisseurs bénéficieraient doivent
être payés à EDF et lorsque ce
trop-plein
dépasse 10%, ça donne lieu à une
sanction financière complémentaire et
que par ailleurs donc nous ouvrons cette
enquête et que nous travaillons sur un
renforcement des pouvoirs de la creux
pour que elle puisse plus rapidement
intervenir puisqu'il faut qu'elle mène
l'enquête aujourd'hui il faut qu'elle
mène l'enquête jusqu'au bout il peut
avoir un délai et ça peut être un enjeu
effectivement de sensibilité vous avez
raison de le souligner sur la
planification écologique la première
ministre étant chargée de cette mission
il est clair que c'est une priorité de
notre gouvernement ce que je ne m'étais
pas en cause la planification écologique
je dis j'ai juste que mon notre objectif
était de travailler et de faire en sorte
que les notamment ce travail sur les
énergies renouvelables que ça doit être
un objet qui sera probablement revu en
dans le cadre de la loi énergie climat
on avait pensé à faire un volet
planification écologique sur la loi
accélération des énergies renouvelables
la difficulté c'est que nous engageons
en parallèle un débat énergique climat
qui est censé animer l'ensemble des
collectivités locales et que nous
revenons six mois plus tard avec une loi
donc il y a un risque de faire une
première loi et de revenir dessus six
mois plus tard donc c'est un point sur
lequel je suis assez d'accord mais
ensuite le moment et la façon de le
faire et probablement l'objet de
l'aspect enfin la stratégie française
énergie climat effectivement d'un débat
qui de toute façon à un moment devra
passer par le Parlement compte tenu de
la nature des textes à prendre ce que
nous ne voulions pas c'était d'empiler
un nouveau schéma vous savez qu'il y a
des stradettes il y a les ppaec enfin et
donc qui finit par compliquer la lecture
de notre action sur le terrain
et c'est donc on peut travailler sur une
planification réelle sur tac tac
sur la question de la de la rénovation
thermique et de la baisse
de l'accompagnement au travers de ma
prime rénove pour rappeler alors nous
avons l'ambition de poursuivre ce
dispositif ma prime rénove nous pouvons
être amenés à l'améliorer c'est une
demande très claire du président de la
République et la première ministre ce
que nous avons constaté premier point
c'est qu'il y a besoin d'accompagnement
et de conseils il y a désormais 500
espaces conseils et 1800 conseillers qui
sont déployés sur le terrain c'est
nouveau vous avez également 5000
personnes qui du réseau Anna et des
autres réseaux accompagnent les ménages
pour mettre en oeuvre leurs projets de
rénovation thermique vous avez 700 000
gestes qui sont accompagnés chaque année
ce ne sont pas tous des rénovations
thermiques profondes et 2000 rénovations
thermiques profondes mais les 700 000
gestes
partie assez importante permettent
d'avoir des gains importants en matière
de consommation énergétique et c'est un
point qui est qui a été encore mis en
valeur par une étude récente sur la
diminution de des émissions de carbone
liées à ce dispositif je pense qu'on
peut encore l'améliorer vous avez
plusieurs dispositifs vous allez le
dispositif prime rénov sereine qui en
gros les rénovations en profondeur il
faut aussi travailler sur les points de
blocage pour le passage à l'acte dans la
rénovation vous avez notamment c'est
souvent au moment des mutations que
c'est réformes ces rénovations se font
et vous avez également les copropriétés
avec un dispositif Haddock mais là
encore ce sont des dossiers plus
complexes donc et il faut effectivement
probablement se poser la question aussi
du rapport ou de la souplesse qu'on se
donne par rapport aux architectes de
bâtiments de France et aussi d'avoir je
dirais des positions relativement
similaires d'une opération à une autre
puisqu'on nous dit on nous remonte que
parfois il y a différentes positions sur
la question de l'autoconsommation
nous avons passé alors vous savez déjà
que le taux consommation a duvet
individuel est exonéré du turc il nous
venons de passer des mesures de soutien
sur l'autoconsommation au Conseil
supérieur de l'énergie du 8 septembre
avec un premier point une prime à
l'investissement versé en une fois et
non plus étalé sur cinq ans donc c'est
vraiment une incitation à investir
deuxième élément c'est la prise en
compte de l'inflation dans la tarif de
revente au réseau c'est ce que nous
avons fait dans l'ensemble des
dispositifs pour accélérer les énergies
renouvelables et le troisième point
c'est le facilitation de l'usage de
l'autoconsommation collective pour les
collectivités parce que là aussi c'est
un point qui remonte quand on y va tout
seul c'est finalement assez simple quand
on y va ensemble ça devient plus
compliqué c'est dommage parce que c'est
plus puissant d'y aller ensemble donc
nous avons apporté cette réponse en
conseil supérieur de l'énergie
sur la question
de la rénovation encore des bâtiments et
conciliation avec le patrimoine je
reviens j'ai répondu en creux sur les
architectes des bâtiments de France
c'est probablement une concertation
qu'il faut avoir et un meilleur travail
pour savoir ce qui on peut s'autoriser à
faire versus ce qui est plus difficile
sur la filière bois comment les
accompagner c'est tout l'enjeu notamment
de la R20 20 qui laisse une place
importante au bois et du comité
stratégique de filière qui prévoit un
certain nombre de mesures
d'accompagnement y compris soutenus au
travers de France relance
sur la sortie du marché électrique
européen je le redis nous ce que nous
proposons c'est une réforme du marché
électrique européen ce n'est pas une
sortie je rappelle que les solidarités
que nous utilisons aujourd'hui pour
permettre à la France d'importer 20
jours par an ces deux dernières années
probablement plus de jours l'année
prochaine elle repose aussi sur le fait
que nous sommes collectivement dans le
marché de l'électricité européen sur la
question des
aides pour acheter du sauté une faille
attends attends sur la question du de la
prolongation du bouclier tarifaire et
des 12 millions de personnes en
situation précaire de précarité
énergétique c'est pas forcément
situation de précarité économique deux
choses la première chose c'est renforcer
les accompagnements pour les personnes
qui sont dans des passoires thermiques
et de faire en sorte de les accompagner
y compris sur tout le parcours client
c'est-à-dire le montage de dossier on
sait que c'est un point de difficulté je
rappelais le projet que enfin le
financement des associations qui
accompagnent les personnes en situation
de précarité énergétique dans leur
projet de rénovation thermique ça peut
paraître très théorique néanmoins si on
arrive à bouter les prêts d'honneur ou
les prêts et les prêts à taux zéros les
soutiens auteurs de 90% des du coût des
opérations l'accompagnement technique et
le fait d'avoir des artisans du Mans
recommandés pour mener le opération à
son terme on arrive à des résultats qui
fonctionnent mais c'est évidemment plus
complexe qu'un simple geste dans une
habitation et évidemment nous allons
faire en sorte que le bouclier est
arrivé soit renforcé pour les personnes
en situation les plus précaires de
manière générale
sur les passoires thermiques il n'y a
pas assez de moyens dites-vous moi je
vous réponds qu'aujourd'hui tous les
carnets de commandes sont remplis et que
mon sujet est moins les moyens
financiers que la réalité d'avoir des
professionnels sur le terrain capables
de mener ces opérations avec deux
questionnements le premier
questionnement comment amener les jeunes
vers ces métiers là parce que nous avons
des CFA qui ne sont pas toujours remplis
et donc un vrai question autour de
l'attractivité des métiers et une
question qui en plus n'est pas forcément
liée au niveau de rémunération parce que
vous avez sur des opérations des niveaux
de rémunération qui ne sont pas du tout
collées au SMIC comme on pourrait se
l'imaginer c'est d'ailleurs souvent le
cas d'un certain nombre de métiers
d'artisanats vous avez des parce que la
rareté fait le prix vous avez des
rémunérations qui peuvent être plus
conséquentes donc des métiers
intéressants qui répondent qui ont du
sens je dirais au regard du combat du
réchauffement climatique donc qui
théoriquement devrait attirer les jeunes
et aujourd'hui on a un écart entre
personnes formées et ont besoin de
formation
sur l'audit du dispositif du parc
alors effectivement EDF alors cette
audit a été fait il a pas été fait par
les personnes d'EDF il a été fait par
une équipe extérieure de professionnels
à la fois du nucléaire mais également de
la conduite de projets complexes et
d'ingénierie il a établi un diagnostic
de l'organisation de la performance
opérationnelle des arrêts de tranche du
parc nucléaire il montre une marge de
progression significative pour
l'entreprise en matière de performance
opérationnelle qui pourrait nous faire
gagner quelques semaines sur les arrêts
c'est pour ça que c'est important sur
les opérations de maintenance et donc ça
sera ça fera partie évidemment des
premières tâches du futur dirigeant
d'EDF de notamment embarquer les
recommandations de cette audit même si
nous savons enfin nous en avons parlé
avec EDF qu'il est largement embarqué
aujourd'hui j'ai demandé à l'entreprise
d'en publier les principales
recommandations parce que je sais qu'il
y a une attente et que c'est important
en de confiance on parlait de confiance
sur le nucléaire d'avoir aussi cette
transparence sur la performance
opérationnelle d'EDF ça me permet de
répondre à l'autre question sur les
réacteurs nucléaires moi mon point de
référence c'est la publication par EDF
de l'ouverture et enfin du redémarrage
et des arrêts de centrales je le
rappelle la loi prévoit que toutes les
démarrages et les arrêts de capacité de
production doivent être communiquées en
temps réel sur un reporting qui
s'appelle remit et qui est accessible à
vous tous vous la retrouvez notamment
sur RTE et clairement j'enjoins EDF à
faire la plus grande transparence sur ce
reporting et à nous permettre d'en faire
un outil de pilotage
puisqu'effectivement c'est sur cette
base là que l'on peut rassurer les
acteurs économiques sur le disponible de
productible nucléaires pour l'hiver
prochain et vous savez que EDF a non
seulement cette
non seulement ce reporting transparent
mais également des éléments sur les
aléas qui peuvent intervenir et que
c'est sur cette base de
reporting complet moi et Léa qu'il
communique sur un dimensionnement de
productive nucléaire pour cet hiver
sur les dispositifs pour les entreprises
saisonnières que cela est joliment dit
donc je pense que vous faites référence
remonter mécanique je sais qu'Olivier
crégoire est à pied d'oeuvre pour
travailler avec cette filière puisque
effectivement elle a des difficultés
particulières je sais également qu'il y
a des mesures qui sont prises de
ralentissement des infrastructures par
principe je me mets de côté même si ça
fait
maintenant 4 ans que j'ai côté cette
industrie je me mets de côté de toutes
les discussions avec cette industrie
dont j'ai opéré un des principaux
acteurs pendant 6 ans
sur la question des infrastructures
gazières ou de biogaz qui pourraient
être développés en savoir peut-être une
précision très clairement et je ferai le
lien ensuite avec mes quatre très
clairement nous nous sommes ouverts à
l'examen de tout infrastructure qui sont
de nature à faciliter la décarbonation
de notre industrie et à renforcer notre
résilience énergétique donc je sais
c'est le principalement notre point
d'entrée donc ensuite sur le projet au
cas particulier il faut l'investiguer et
l'instruire et donc même approche pour
1004 pour mid cat qui est donc cette
infrastructure gaziaire qui relierait
qui est un projet qui relirait l'Espagne
à la France pour passer plus de gaz
plusieurs éléments le premier élément
c'est que compte tenu et je pense que
vous êtes bien placé pour le savoir des
temps d'instruction d'autorisation et de
construction des projets en France il
est illusoire de dire qu'une telle
infrastructure pourrait se mettre en
place dans les 24 mois qui viennent je
le redis si on fait un projet d'éolienne
en 7 ans et il est assez peu probable de
faire une infrastructure gazières
dimensionnante deux mois du coup cette
infrastructure n'est pas malheureusement
un élément de résilience dans la crise
ukrainienne ou la crise énergétique
auquel nous faisons face si maintenant
nous prenons une perspective plus
lointaine c'est de se dire est-ce qu'on
construit une infrastructure gaziaire
qui aurait vocation à sortir en 2030 là
ça pose un problème clair c'est que on
investit dans une autre structure
fossile au moment où on organise la
décarbonation de notre système
énergétique donc il y a effectivement
une incohérence si maintenant il s'agit
de faire une infrastructure pour
l'hydrogène alors discutons d'une
infrastructure pour l'hydrogène et le
président de la République a été clair
en fait l'infrastructure qui est
probablement la plus de nature à
faciliter le déploiement d'une
comment dire d'un réseau hydrogène en
Europe entre la France et l'Espagne sur
une interconnexion électrique
complémentaire ou le renforcement des
interconnexions électriques existantes
puisqu'elles fournirait sur la base
énergie verte l'ensemble des
électrolyseurs européens or c'est ça la
valeur ajoutée que peut fournir
l'Espagne c'est un point que j'ai
discuté avec Teresa Ribera et sur lequel
je précise qu'elle était d'accord
vendredi c'est à dire de se réunir sur
les éléments suivants point 1 faire la
carte graphie des infrastructures
capables de venir en appui du plan de
solidarité de résilience de l'hiver
prochain et regardez ce qui est le plus
facilement activable deuxième élément
faire le plan pour l'hydrogène et
regarder ce qui est effectivement
nécessiterait d'être construit
troisièmement discuter des rentes de
congestion puisque l'Espagne a le
sentiment de mettre à disposition
l'électricité à bas prix qui aujourd'hui
profiterait aux Français et nous nous
avons pas le sentiment là donc nous
sommes prêts à payer les rentes de
cogestion dans un délai enfin sur 6 ou 8
mois en contrepartie d'avoir un
approvisionnement réel en électricité et
quatrième point c'est un point de
convergence de soutenir un modèle
ibérique pour le plafonnement du prix
du gaz au niveau européen
madame la ministre bravo pour toutes ces
réponses tenues en 20 minutes de très
nombreuses questions et 20 minutes de
temps de réponse donc merci d'avoir pris
le temps de répondre à la représentation
nationale et si d'autres questions
venaient à émerger de façon de vous
interroger également et de contacter
votre cabinet qui est à notre écoute
quand on a des questions à poser chers
collègues nous ont pris beaucoup de
retard nous avons une audition qui
commence incessamment sous peu je vous
propose une suspension de 7 minutes
avant de redémarrer sur l'audition tout
à l'heure de Monsieur Klein je vous
remercie